hello hello everybody um i might have made a little oopsie
by streaming till 7 a.m yesterday maybe maybe just a teensy
weensy little oopsie by doing a seven plus hour stream last
night um because um i forgot next week i have to use my
voice a lot uh during my business trip so i was just Like,
and I plan around the fact that, oh, I can stream as long as
I want this week because I'll be gone next week.
And then after the stream last night, I was like, oh, fuck,
wait, I have to use my voice.
I, oh, oh, fuck.
Okay, I cannot fuck up my voice this week.
So I did plan a lot of long streams this week, but they
might not be that long in the end.
they might not if i've been really bad that i started off
the week with a seven plus hour stream just a teensy-weezy
little oopsie if it isn't the consequences of my own actions
all right also i just realized i also discounted the days
again i don't know i don't know what's with me with numbers
guys like whatever you give me numbers somehow some way i'll
mess it up somehow some So I had it all planned out where
basically I was like I'm gonna do early access of the James
Bond game And I thought tomorrow was the early access of the
James I don't know why I thought tomorrow was the 26th So
today I was like we're all these people getting all these
James Bond clips Isn't it the early access tomorrow?
How did they all these big streamers are able to play the
game a day a day earlier than a Early access.
That's not fair.
Where's my streamer?
And I realized, oh, it's today.
It is today.
I was like, oh, wait, it's today.
So it should have been today where I played James Bond.
Now I'm a day late.
And now actually, it's all right.
And me being a day late means you guys can backseat me if I
get lost.
That's fine.
But I'm looking forward to tomorrow.
because apparently all the reviews came in and a lot of
street and on steam it's mostly positive it seems very uh
positive right now on steam and all the reviewers are saying
like oh it was like game of the year contender nine or ten
out of ten yeah it seems like it looks really cool um
apparently the game was like in development hell so they
have a lot of like what's the word They have a lot of
references that might have that did not age very well There
are a lot of like influencers in there that might have
already retired being influencers Because of how long it
took to make this game So it's going to be interesting To
see I mean I heard jacksepticeye is in there But also the
the guy who the the tick tock star or something that doesn't
talk or anything He just points at things he's like super
retired now because he sold his entire face to ai so he
doesn't have to make content anymore because he basically
like anybody can use his image now um uh for profit because
he literally sold his entire image uh to ai so he can like
so he can like basically retire um um but yeah i'm looking
forward to tomorrow trying out the james bond game uh uh
because of like I mean, it's not like a mixtape situation
where it's just like reviewers are raving about it.
And then the general audience is like, what the fuck is this
game?
But it's like, uh, apparently it's like even the general
audiences and also reviewers love the game.
So I'm looking forward to try up James Bond.
Shake it not stirred.
Wow.
Um, okay, I shouldn't talk too much about James Bond because
we can talk about that tomorrow.
Uh, what else do I want to talk about?
Oh, yes.
For those who don't know, who are not.
not you know who are not degenerates like me um and stayed
up from um midnight to seven in the morning watching me play
subnautica rivals and apex legends uh next week i will be
gone you're like where is she talking about next week uh
didn't read my community post next week i will be gone on a
business trip for a work trip um i will try and sneak in a
stream or two because I did not expect myself to be I didn't
expect it to be a week I thought it was like a three to four
day situation um and they were like oh we need you there for
a week and I was like oh fuck okay okay all right like I but
I do want to stream I promise this it's not like a Japan
situation where I was like don't worry guys I'll stream at
least one time and then I disappeared and I disappeared and
almost killed my channel but this time this time look I had
I mean I met guys I was like I disappeared and they're like
what happened to her and I'm like I'm just like here I am
traveling around the world we never see her again and I
definitely came back for milk um but this time this time I
promise you guys we will sneak at least one or two streams
um during this work trip because actually sort of I just
wanted it stream honestly but obviously I couldn't, I
couldn't, um, what's the word?
Um, uh, you know, it's an obligation that I have to travel.
So, um, I can't say what it is.
It'll all be revealed soon, TM.
Not very, very soon, but soon, TM.
So, uh, just a little FYI.
Um, I don't know.
I've been traveling a lot this year.
There's just so many opportunities for this year alone
that's been popping up where I do have to.
to travel a lot.
I'm not a person, I'm a person who doesn't like traveling a
lot too, by the way.
I just don't, I don't know, I just don't like sitting in
planes.
I feel like the older I get, the more, like I don't, I don't
necessarily have fear of flying, but it's getting there.
I don't know.
I was like, I'm raising, I'm like, I'm raising the odds
right now.
Every time I take a plane i'm raising the odds against me
because i've been flying since i was really young and so so
um so it's like i feel like i don't know the older i get i'm
just like this might be it this might be the day i become a
wikipedia article so and i find it out to be fair i haven't
had much plane rides too and a very like honestly like it's
it's like a 50 50 it's like a 50 50 on if my if my plane
ride is gonna be okay every flight's a gotcha um but uh but
you know obviously um i had to take these opportunities i i
had to take these opportunities and um it's they're really
great opportunities and i'm super excited for everything
that's coming for this year i do miss doing creative
projects projects i know you guys might have seen like i
haven't done a lot of creative projects these the last two
years um because of all the other were like all the other
like business projects going on behind the scenes uh but um
i think oh my gosh sorry my brain just fucking sort of
dedicated just now but um but these are all amazing things
amazing opportunities and you know if I don't take them I
might never get these opportunities again so yeah I take
them while I still can but you guys are gonna you guys are
gonna enjoy all the cool new stuff that's coming in for 2026
with all this traveling that I'm doing I don't know how
other vtubers do it I personally like I don't know how all
these vtubers travel so much and do all these things and
meet up with so many people I I just like staying at home
you know what I learned what I learned traveling I like
staying at home I like just being at home streaming I like
being at home guys I it's very comfy I hope but I hope next
year I travel oh man I don't want to say I want to travel
less because guess what if I don't get okay I I hope next
year I balance more of the traveling and streaming because I
do miss, I do, I do really love streaming for you guys.
I love streaming for you dragons.
So every time I have to travel, I'm just like, whoa, I want
to make content.
I want to, I want to stream and hang out.
I want to play video games.
I want to play, I want to play some video games.
I don't care.
but uh but they are great opportunities though like you know
i did make a lot of cool memories i made a lot of new
friends and met a lot of really really cool people like i
don't regret it at all but you know sometimes deep down
you're just like i want to stay at home just want to be a uh
a home bird but it's fun i feel like if i uh you know i feel
like never make these types of memories experience ever
again too type deal where this is like a one of one of a
kind opportunity too um yeah dude i could be gaming right
now
um oh what else what else what else i want to talk about my
brain is my one brain cells like fighting for dominance
right now they're like please listen to me and i'm like
like the previous like that's not the time for that tokyo
it's not the time for that uh but yeah like i said met so
many cool amazing people and you know i did need the
vacation too when i was got like when i disappeared in japan
for two plus weeks i i really didn't need it because i was
like like frying my my was like short like my i was actually
so fried um but it really did also I just love hanging out
with you guys too and how much I love streaming and I don't
want to take that for granted as well.
Anyway, what else?
Oh yeah, Lego Batman.
Did you guys know I found out that Lego Batman is
technically better than Red Dead Redemption 2 in texture
quality?
Did you guys see that?
Did you guys see that tweet?
Apparently, if you zoom in on the Lego, you can see...
You can see like the texture for I mean it really did take
almost 10 years for this for it It did take almost 10 years
to reach that point But yeah, apparently the texture quality
on Lego Batman is more HD than Red Dead Redemption.
They've done it Lego Batman is now higher quality than RDR2
we've done it we had a new benchmark it's your gate is if
your game is good is it as good as lego batman though it's a
fucking lego block oh yeah also um i try to play scrabble um
online last night because i was trying to come up with new
stream ideas for like collabs and stuff and i was like what
if i play scrabble and then i try to play scrabble against
an easy ai and like they were coming up with words that i
didn't even know existed and all i was putting down was like
ran yang can rat and then he then the the ai was like was
like catapult uh pulling up uh like pull ups uh trash can
and i was like why are there so many letters i was like
pre-natal oh my god one of them was like pre-natal i was
like what the how i thought this was easy i thought what i
thought this was like what what are these words that my ai
easy bot is i was just like i was like i can't i don't think
i can play scrabble with a bunch of other vtubers I I think
it would I I was just literally putting it down like
three-letter words and I was just like And then there and
I'm you know I started running out of three-letter words.
So I was just like Rats how
I just I was just putting s's on on nouns I was like I was
like Rating
So, so I was just like, I don't know.
I was just thinking, this is my dot work.
I'm just going to be putting, I'm going to be like, skip
word.
And then I'll be like, I don't know.
And then they were going to be put up more fucking crazy ass
words with like eight letter words.
I was like, how are you coming up with these eight letter
words?
How is this possible?
I need a fucking dictionary.
I need an...
Yeah, no, I was putting the S at the end.
I was putting S at the end of my words to get points.
And then my AI Easy bot was just making new words.
And there were longer than three letters.
I was like, how is that possible?
There's words longer than three letters?
How is that possible?
How does he do it?
How does, do they do it?
Anyway, I don't know if I should set up a collab playing
Scrabble.
I feel like it's not going to look so good for me.
Or anyone I've, because I'm just like, I don't even know we
can do it.
I don't know.
It might look a little embarrassing.
It will be okay, Doki.
Every VTuber live is the NSL.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel like, no, I feel like the game will end very fast.
thinking of I I think it was before it was before the stream
it was um it was like around like like evening time before
the stream and I was just like try and test out stream ideas
like collab games and stuff it's like I was like oh my I was
like oh my god this is brilliant idea what if I what if I
play Scrabble like oh my god so brilliant it's so smart
dokey oh I haven't seen scrabble yet and then I was like oh
my god what if I organize a scrabble collab and I was like
let me test this website out because obviously for some
reason um I guess they lost the licensing but there used to
be a scrabble online and then they lost the licensing like
on steam um but that doesn't exist no more so I was testing
websites out for scrabble but didn't look very pretty I mean
it doesn't like didn't look very pretty for me when it comes
to plain scrabble I was getting
destroyed i may or may not have been getting absolutely
destroyed by the easy ai by next to you thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you sometimes it's hard to
reconcile your vocabulary with the fact you have a degree
thank you the super chat next to you thank you um all right
let's go play lego batman
also i fucked on my sleep schedule i forgot to tell you guys
that i think it's obvious when i stopped the stream at 7 in
the morning but may or may not have woke up at 4 p.m now and
it's getting a little worse a lot the longer we go because
at first it was like you know 10 a.m and then 12 p.m and
then 1 p.m and then 2 p.m and then 3 p.m and now it's 4 p.m
this is maybe soon if i keep pushing it by an hour okay i
need to fix it by tomorrow because i have a 12 30 stream
that's not great i just realized i have to fix this by
Yeah, I was going to say, it'll come full circle at some
point.
If it keeps...
It's like there's a pattern.
It's every hour.
So it'll loop back to a decent sleep schedule.
But I realized I have to fix it by today.
It needs to be fixed by the end of the day.
Anyway, it's Batman.
man time.
Ah, this is where my parents die.
Oh my god, Batman.
Jakarta, I think the Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
I can't stay up, though.
Oh, wait, I can stay up, though.
I haven't had, I haven't taken a nap in a while.
I'm proud of myself.
That's, that's an accomplishment.
That's accomplishment for me.
I haven't taken a nap for a while.
Also, I know I have three series to finish now i made a
little oopsie with that and for so i guess because it's
summer oh my gosh why am i lagging maybe i get in the game i
wouldn't be lagging maybe maybe it's the menu thing maybe it
maybe it's just menus things guys oh and shaders are still
compiling oh okay whoops all right give me a oh all right
let's go back we need to get the power back on to run our
analysis I didn't even see the compiling shaders part.
Alright, keep on compiling.
You go do your thing.
Alright, let's compile shaders.
What was I saying before I realized I was lagging?
Don't worry, we're at 2%.
I was just like, what the fuck?
Oh yeah, see, my food's gonna be here in nine minutes.
I didn't eat anything yet.
Oh, fuck.
What was I talking about before I got distracted with the...
with the compiling shaders.
Yeah, it's slow.
Guys, that's why Red Dead Redemption 2.
That's how it beats Red Dead Redemption 2, guys.
I gotta be able to look at the the rain texture on the Lego.
Too many games.
Yeah.
So many games have... I think it's because it's summer, you
know?
So many games have have started releasing this month and
next month.
Like, if they all lined up for like summer vacation and
everything and uh because ah it's like all these games are
releasing there's a new batman game there's a james bond
game and i've and i started arm record and then and then you
know what fucking sucks i apparently next week next week
they're uh they're doing summer game fest um state of play
and the xbox uh game announcement all next week all next
week i was like i'm gone next week ah i'm so mad because
it's like why next week can't they just wait one more week
for me yeah all the showcases i'm so upset i'm so mad and i
can't i don't i can't even i don't i can't even do a watch
along stream too and i'm on the, because, like, I don't
think the schedule aligns for it for me.
So I'm just, unless I like, I have to, to, like, look at the
schedule again, but, ah!
I wish I could, I wanted to, like, watch it with you guys.
Yeah, don't they know who I am?
Um, I'm a VTuber.
I'm pretty important.
Yeah.
I'm sure so sad i can't believe it the timing of everything
too has been so unfortunate oh my god we're only at 28 each
each lego it's like a snowflake each lego block is different
you'll never find two lego blocks are the same they pre-rend
they've rendered not even pre-rendered they've rendered a
million lego blocks for this game guys and each lego blocks
each tiny lego block is like 800 like a thousand triangles
that's a thousand plus polygons uh jacquardo they give us a
super chat they look at the game yeah and like 60% of those
Lego blocks of those mini figures wear capes too so they
have the hand they hand textured each of those textures you
see was hand painted by the 3d artists they didn't use they
didn't copy or paste anything they've hand drawn it and they
drawn it on a 10,000 by 10,000 canvas Each cape, and it's
each cape, too.
Jakato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All parts for Lego Doki are official Lego parts.
So if someone wanted to make either Lego Doki or Lego Bat
Doki, they can.
Jakato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's so cool.
That's really cool.
You can build your own, like, mini-figure, like, VTuber
mini-figures.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now that we are talking over a Lego game, did you see about
the guy that got scammed of his whole father's Lego Star
Wars collection?
No, I didn't.
What happened about him?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Gus.
Please excuse the lagging.
I'm compiling shaders.
I'm like 5 FPS right now.
I guess I'm from the 80s or some shit.
I'm a Mario game where I have three sprites.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's 2026.
We have SSCs.
We thought loading times were a thing of the past, but UE5
said compiling shaders.
Yeah, they're releasing Unreal Engine 6.
Who is their first victim?
him?
I don't remember.
Apparently, yeah.
Unreal Engine 6 is coming out soon.
Is it Rocket League?
Oh yeah, it's always Rocket League.
Yeah.
Give it to the story.
But they change.
Oh, now they refuse to return or set or close after losing
in small cores.
Oh.
That sucks, bro.
That really sucks.
What was I going to say?
There was something else I want to talk about.
Oh my god, it slipped my mind.
See, this is what I'm talking about.
I was like, I'll remember this topic later.
It literally just slipped my mind in five seconds.
Let's see.
Oh, it's a wild.
Yeah, I mean, that's pretty wild.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Riddle me this dokey bird.
Batman versus Bane.
Both buck naked.
oil who's winning the twerk off i think we're all winning
we're all winning here uh gordon thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you i can't write the notes down while
i'm talking mid conversation guys it's really happening live
right now can't just do that
Oh my god, my food's gonna be here in three minutes.
I'm getting a taco.
Yeah, I haven't had Mexican food in a while, so I'm gonna
get a taco.
Oh my god, they're doing everything brick by brick right
now.
They're actually, like, rendering each brick into the game.
I got...
What are they compiling?
What are they adding to this game?
what kind of taco i don't know i just saw in the menu and
saw a lot i don't need a lot of mexican food because i was
i'm uh because canna's so far from from mexico if you think
about it so i didn't really grew up with like mexican food
and um also i lived in asia for 10 years as well Asia is
also, if you guys think about it, Asia is also very far away
from Mexico too.
It's not very popular in Asia.
So I didn't grow up eating Mexican food.
I need to find, what did, where did I even order this from?
Chinese food exists in Canada.
Yeah, because, you know, because like there's a lot of
Chinese immigrants in canada because a lot of chinese people
move to canada for immigration but uh there's not not a lot
of people uh in south america or mexico immigrated to canada
so it wasn't very popular back then when i was growing up um
you can easily get chinese food but you can't really get you
can't really find a good like mexican place when i was
growing up yeah
uh taco tuesday space Sorry.
Didn't give the super chat.
Thank you.
Trying to find the restaurant.
I don't even remember.
Okay.
It's... It even even has tacos in it.
I have...
I got the...
Vamp... Wait.
What is this?
Asada.
It's deep fried corn tortilla with beef steak on top.
I got the asada.
But cheese and beefsteak.
I learned what an Asada was yesterday.
Oh no, this week.
Karn Asada.
I still don't know what it is.
But I learned the word.
I don't know what it is.
But I know.
I learned the word.
Karn Asada.
Fertula.
With.
Yes right.
fried corn tequila oh wait does it mean roasted meat oh hey
i'm yay we finished compiling shaders let's go all right
let's go it's batman time cutie cry thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you oh that reminds me you know this
he's like fully retired now oh my god that guy's made it
have a beautiful girlfriend, got married, have a beautiful
kid, live in Japan.
And then now he's like fully retired because he's planning
on stopping his family vlogs now because he wants his son to
have like, yeah, but as in like he's even stopping the
family vlogs now because he wants to give his son privacy.
So he's like, yeah, we're not doing these vlogs.
We're not doing it anymore.
Anyway, happy birthday, PewDieCry.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear PewDieCry.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
He also got original fan art.
Oh, why can't I even say fan art?
Okay, he's basically canon in Attack on Titan because he got
official art from them when he visited their studio.
and this guy has made it next to you thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you he also survived 20 plus
cancellations he survived god and can cancel 20 plus times
good i can barely see a thing all right
where i go i guess i had to do this let me place this in oh
wait i need find it oh i found it it's always place say i
have an opportunity to watch your live stream i came over
request can you say i okay let me make sure what that means
because if i say everything that people want me to say um
one day i might say something really bad so i gotta be
careful Let me check what that means.
Yeah, just say stuff right off the bat.
I gotta be sure.
It doesn't mean anything bad.
Who's this guy?
Okay.
This guy is a champion, but who is this guy?
I hope...
I need to know if this guy is a bad person or not oh he's a
football player okay damn almost got her castle okay it's a
local football team okay all right all right that's all
right okay i was gonna say at least as long as he's not a
war criminal then that's fine uh uh huibo cruise azol
champion i think i that was i almost sound
Man, I think that was pretty good.
Let's see if the computer can tell us what Red Hood 1 is
hidden in this bear.
I think that sounded pretty native, guys.
Honestly, you're just jealous.
I'm trying to remember...
Let me see, I'm trying to remember all the controls right
now.
It's been a while.
Okay, there's that.
Okay, there's my batter.
All right.
Can't just yet.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
I know I sound like almost fluent there.
You're going to check that bear on your computer, right?
All right.
Place the bear.
Analyzing.
Enhancing.
Let's analyze it.
I'm sure you will not make it out of.
That'll keep us busy.
What does that mean?
You can construct my new workbench while you meet.
I know.
Where are you?
The super chat thingy.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
making my crib right now hello hello commissioner Gordon
welcome to my crib why am I oh yeah that set everything up I
missed those MTV shows that was some good-ass reality TV not
not not too trashy back then my sweet 16 was like the
trashiest you can see fine and well actually no no there
were worse I remember there was like so we smashing those
crates or what i'm trying to remember there was like a worst
reality the tv show that mtv did i'm trying to remember the
premise oh wait never mind there was one where they stranded
chill well it wasn't mtv but i feel like mtv had some good
classics like my sweet 16 uh welcome to my crib the pranking
show oh fear factor i missed fear fear factor was fun Yeah.
Yeah, I was thinking about Kid Nation.
But there was, like, some really fucked up...
There's, like, one really fucked up reality TV show where...
Basically, the audience will decide if you have...
Like, you're trying to decide if this lady had a butterface
or not.
And that's, like, so fucked up.
I just remember that.
W.
I'll get some use out of this.
there's like a bunch of late like bunch of girls would go up
in like bikinis and they would wear a paper bag or something
and then they're like does she have a butterface or not and
then like like the audience was like butterface they'd be
like no butterface and then like they would take off and
then then they would take off the bag and like she didn't
even look that bad like what the fuck is a butterface
butterface is like people don't use that anymore it's like
old lingo but it's but like the face is what's ruined like
quote-unquote ruins it so like the face is not like it's
like a five out of ten but the body is a 10 out of 10 and
that's what butterface is so yeah everything is good but her
face so oh yeah that's but her face that's what butterface
oh my god that's what it means yeah so um and there was a
show where people like and then like but then the girls
there weren't even that bad.
And I watched a clip where they're like, why did, like the
guy was interviewing the girl.
And he's like, why did you join the show?
And she's like, oh, I didn't even sign up for this.
My friends, my friends signed me up for it.
And I was like, that's fucked up.
That's, that's fucked up.
Your friend signed you up on the competition.
Like, that ain't no friend, girl.
That ain't no friend.
All right, nice.
Improve the technology.
I can upgrade my equipment here.
Oh, nice.
Oh, hey, nice.
Okay, purchase batter and combo.
Oh, my God.
More batter and...
Okay, how much do I have?
I have seven.
I have six.
I'm sorry, I still can't count.
Okay.
But no, I realized shows back then had less, like less
regulations.
It's like how they, they, in the toddlers and tiaras, they
would dope their kids with lots of sugar.
Of course.
Jim, we're heading back to the city.
Alright, back to the city we go.
I got a friend with a better one.
Let's go.
all right oh we oh all right i look so cool i don't remember
how to glide i think i don't oh wait i don't think i have
that upgrade i think the gliding the glide has to be an
upgrade or something all right let's go we have to go back
to the city
Hello?
We have to go back to the city?
Back to the city?
Oh, oh, oh, back to the city!
Whoa, let's think of this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Apparently, Rock City co-developed this game with TD.
That's sick.
Think of this super chat.
Thank you.
We're heading to South Island.
the city deserves a hero and that's me they just reopened
the bridge i'm that hero don't worry citizens i will save
the day nothing to be worried about your hero is finally
here i'm batman that's right no need to worry citizens of
gotham i shall protect you all from these criminal scums.
Yoker.
You're from Chicago.
That's right.
Don't worry, I'll take you to your destination.
You're the Gotham can't do hot dogs right.
Well, at least we've got better pizza.
That's true.
That's the why everyone keeps staying in Gotham.
Every one thing else sucks, but hey, the pizza's great.
The vehicle would be a bad idea.
What do you mean?
I'm literally right here.
mission i still can't believe it what night carmine falcony
behind bars teddy bear stuff with chemicals secret caves
hidden by waterfalls i mean oh hey you're hungry hungry i'm
starved and don't suppose you get too many oh he's trying to
ditch him he's just like finally this is a solo act oh yeah
oh i remember now um so originally matara wanted to play
lego games for our collab but But all Lego games are only
local couch co-op.
So she was like, she didn't want to do like remote.
Because like the only way to do multiplayer is that if we do
remote play, only one person can use a controller.
Because you can't have two controllers in remote play.
So I was like, oh, but I was like, it's okay.
We can find another game.
And then we found that I saw that Deep Rock Galactic
released a new multiplayer game called...
What was it?
The Rogue would.
My height dressed as a...
Hang on, Janice.
A bat?
No.
Sorry, officer.
Get a swirny came in here.
Yeah, Rogue Court.
Yeah, I'm glad.
Like, what good timing.
Rogue Court released, like, last week, too.
Make the manly shape you want.
Huh.
Manly shape.
Above you is a carbon-by-weave glider developed for the
GCPD.
Was that American Psycho reference?
Yeah, I was going to say.
Oh, cool.
Yoink.
Let's just say.
Not stealing because I own this company.
Morgan Freeman.
He's like almost 90, though, isn't he?
Oh, my God.
Look, that's God.
Let's see if we can't work out what your little friend has
made of.
That man's literally Morgan Freeman.
The bear, I mean.
Look, I'd rather nobody knew about.
Mr. Wayne, if you don't want to tell me exactly what you're
doing, I mean, I could just fire him if he rats me out.
I mean, to be fair, I could kill him too.
I'm a billionaire.
What's it supposed to happen, right?
What if I just press the button again?
Power cells lying around here somewhere.
Alright.
The power cells haven't been inserted yet.
Where am I supposed to move this?
Oh, over there.
Alright, we got fired.
What is he gonna do, huh?
If he rats me out, he's fucking dead.
I'm unstoppable, I'm a billionaire.
One down, two to go.
A few finishing touches and this could retrieve that power
cell.
Just need to find one.
Oh, there it is.
Can you get these things out of here?
Fuck these tires!
You shouldn't, though.
He's guide.
want to throw in, you're right.
I can't throw in God.
Oh, fuck that minus boost.
Oh, there you go.
Now I can build.
Oh, hardcore.
I'm sure Lucius has the parts to finish this thing.
There you go.
Alright, one more to go.
You know what would be easier if we have a fucking ladder,
Lucius.
Another power cell.
I'm amazed we could find anything in this place.
You want to be very convenient in this basement where
everything is stored on like shelves.
Maybe a ladder.
Maybe a ladder would be pretty neat.
Man, that sucks that Lego games don't have...
But it looks so cool, dokey.
But it sucks that Lego games don't have...
Oh, there it is.
Don't have, like, multiple...
Oh, that's just a light.
I don't know.
It's just they're all Lego bricks, guys.
That's a workbench.
It's where you upgrade your gadgets and gear.
It sucks that Lego games don't have online multiplayer.
I feel like it's such a good game for online multiplayer,
too.
Oh, it's literally right here.
It's blue and the floor is blue.
It blends perfectly well.
That's all the power cells.
Let's hook them up to the machine and see what's in spare.
Especially for this game, I feel like, you know, for the new
generation, think that they would put they would add online
multiplayer for it and but all you can do is just local
coach co-op and it sucks that when you try to do remote play
or parsec you can only have one controller hooked on i do
not like matara and i both did not want to play both did not
want to play lego like both want to play the lego game on
mouse and keyboard because it's so controller
coded all right i'm gonna analyze i'm
analyzing What am I doing?
I'm rotating.
I'm...
Oh!
They...
I'm so smart.
It's like this game is made for kids or something.
Guys, I am smart in the fifth grader.
I think I solved the puzzle.
Okay.
Look at that.
H-E-H-E.
Also known as Lafonium.
Not dangerous in its own right.
But, when mixed in the right way to put any number of
components...
Oh?
Quite lethal.
I need to find the rest of those bears.
Plural?
Oh, I know that movie reference!
parents watch these movies wait residents Alfred speaking
Alfred run a trace on Red Hood's chopper we need to find
it's not the jungler it's Red Hood I need a way to cover
more ground I just ate 30 years thanks to me I was thinking
like what do you mean borrow I literally only this company
he's like um can i have permission to use my own stuff
all right let's go complete mission that's my food's here
let me go grab oh after this credit after this cut scene
yeah i'm gonna say what do you mean borrow i i'm literally
the number one investor
Gordon stop doing that hey why did you call me here we need
the height to test the glide glide
all right what happens if I don't test the glide oh okay I
have If they kneel, they fucking kneel.
They're like, we're going to pause the game until you press
it.
Yay.
I can increase it.
These gliders are a game changer, Jim.
We're no longer tied to just patrolling the streets.
The streets is where the crime is.
I have so much money.
When do I get to spend?
this let's go faster oh i'm gliding there's just a lot of
wind in gotham city rim must be super cheap though because
isn't if i remember like it depends on like which um which
batman lore you're looking at but like metropolis is like
literally almost next door it depends on which which
universe it is is like metropolis which is superman city is
like down the street so why would you pick you know it's
like why would you pick gothic city when you're literally
across the street from uh metropolis sorry metropolis
all right open the door how do i open the door
i did it oh i have to build all right let me grab my There
must be parts around here.
Let me go grab my food real quick.
I got my tortilla, my tortilla with my corn assada, assada.
My corn assada with my tortilla taco.
This.
Why are you...
Someone stop or at least...
Ooh.
Ooh, there's my corn of Seda.
Rage made successful.
I'm so fluent.
I'm almost like a native speaker.
I know.
Huh?
No quassadillas?
No, not today.
No quassadillas.
Today.
Just my...
I would say I'm not a fan of lime or lemon on any of my
food.
I know.
You've always judged me for that.
I just don't like the acidity.
Not an acidity Christian.
The sauce.
Hola.
Muy bien.
All the Spanish that I learned is from Dora the Explorer.
Bambino's.
Dora.
Oh my god.
So spicy.
Oh!
The green sauce.
What is this?
Oh my god.
green sauce.
It's so spicy.
I took a spoonful and licked it.
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Oh, it's so spicy.
Oh my god.
That is so spicy.
I had a spice pot, but this is spicy.
This is so good.
Like, I I took a spoon And just licked it
That was not a good idea Oh, I should not have just licked
it I should have just I was like, what is this sauce?
I was like, it wasn't like a tiny lick, too I was like, yeah
I was like Then I was like, oh Oh Oh
Oh my god.
Oh, it still stings.
Okay, that was a bad idea.
Oh, drinking water makes it worse, too.
I don't have milk, either.
It was a lot.
Time to get airborne.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, why did I get myself into this mess?
Oh my god.
I'm just helping the food.
Soaks the spice away.
It's really bad.
Oh, why did I lick the spoon?
Why did I lick the spoon, guys?
Why did I do that?
Donkey, no.
No.
Oh, I had to open the door.
But...
You opened the door?
It's like, bitch, don't close the door on me.
My door's a sliding door.
So you literally pushed the sliding door over.
You got back in.
It's like, bitch, don't close that door.
I'm talking to you.
No, he knows how to open doors.
But like more so, he just knows how to push.
He knows that when you push a door, it opens.
You just become too powerful.
So the thing is my bathroom door, it's like, he's like a
cat.
So my bathroom door, even when I close it, it doesn't close
fully in.
So if he pushes it, he can open the door.
So sometimes we're not pooping.
He's like, I want to watch you.
That's what doesn't help to have heated floors.
My bathroom tiles are heated so it's comfy for him too.
So he would come in and be like, hi.
Let me sit down.
And just watch you poop.
You're in the bathroom a little too long.
I got to know what's going on.
so because i would close the door but he can open it because
all he has to do is just push the door and then he comes in
like it doesn't stop it but he doesn't do it every time at
least so it's not like an actual problem plot problem but
sometimes he likes to miss me in the bathroom and i can't do
anything about it
i guess he's like you wash me poop i watch you poop maybe
he's like maybe that's the relationship we have you know it
was just like i thought that's what we have you know i get
to watch you poop you get to watch me poop i'm just giving
you what you give me so i have another one but i'm full
right now so i'm gonna put this away i think i'm like a one
and done right now we're poop buddies yeah oh my god i don't
know why didn't see it but on top of the fucking the one
that was really spicy the container at the top at the top of
the lid which of course i didn't read it says hot at the top
of the lid i didn't read it sadly sadly i that i missed that
it said hot the other lid had Did not have anything else.
Here, I'll take a picture.
A fucking horse that says hot.
Okay, but they got hot.
Apparently, it was hot.
They were right.
Okay, I took a picture of it so you guys can see.
Hot.
Oh, my God.
I'm like, my nose is running.
It was definitely hot.
My nose is running.
now oh my god it was so spicy and then i literally took a
spoon because i wanted to try to you know how you want to
try the sauce up but before you put it on things i took the
spoon and i but didn't do like a tiny scoop i did like maybe
not not a very tiny scoop yeah i was like oh and i was like
oh it was a slow hitter too it was a slow burn i was like
we're not so bad it's like why is it tongue getting spicy in
the sink starting to sting why is it starting to sting my
tongue right now oh it's it's getting a little worse maybe
it'll stop it didn't stop oh but now now it's getting pretty
bad maybe it's gonna stop it still didn't stop all right
there it is hot
yeah it creeps up on you
oh all right let me actually i'll just put this over here
it's i didn't read the lid i just opened the lid i didn't
realize there were words on the lid
i literally just opened it and put it away who would have
known who would have known
Alright, Batman time.
Oh, I should wash my hands.
You're still right.
Give me a second to wash my hands.
Don't want to go blind, accidentally.
So Nora found dad.
He was in the bathroom, right?
He was like, yeah.
He heard you talking shit.
Yeah, he was in the bathroom.
What?
Okay, I was gonna say.
Yeah, he thought I was heading to the bathroom.
She's like, I'm here.
I'm waiting for you.
Ricardo, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Did you need to poop too?
You want me to watch you again?
All units.
The citizen is getting hassled by some guys in Red Mask.
The camera came off rail station.
That's right over there.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, shit.
What was that?
Oh, don't worry.
I'll help you.
They're like, where did he go?
I'm not prepared.
Oh.
Look out, Gordon.
Oh, that's awkward.
What is he going to do, huh?
That's right.
Oh, to be fair, I feel like...
To be fair, I feel like we...
Oh, oops, sorry, Gordon.
I don't really need...
I feel like I have a lot of points, I will say.
I think I have more than enough coins.
Right, I'm more than enough bricks.
Oh, nice.
He has a gun.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Batman time.
That's our friendly fire!
I don't really use the combo, the, my special move.
the gcpd are you okay ma'am thank you officer i uh and
batman work
on your people skills i'm a billionaire i'll need to work on
people skills people come to me i've got a bead on that
chopper sending you the location now when you have enough
money you can be as anti-social as you want i'll make you a
nice little cocoa when you get back i'm not sure critical.
Some of those little marshmallows you like.
Affirmative.
Over.
That's a life lesson.
I wonder if Elon thinks he's still in the simulation.
Oh shit!
He filled all of that?
I wonder if they'll include like Alfred's superhero persona.
What's his name again?
It's enough.
Uh, because Alfred at one point was a superhero too.
Red Hood 1 is taking those bears.
I want to start flying.
He does have one.
He was, ah, what is it called?
It was something really stupid.
Unless that was a...
like I'm trying to remember what it's called he had an alter
ego too no he did the macaroni yes I don't know that was
just the I don't know if that was made up for the Harley
Quinn show or if he really was the macaroni the macaroni man
I can smell it I don't know if that's from a comic or not
hood wants choppers on the helipad it's canon to me yeah it
apparently alfred's been dead for seven plus years and
they're introducing a new alfred who's a woman a woman
butler oh my god
three more shipments we're here now ain't we get moving we
need to analyze all three bears find out what red hood one
is cooking i'll give you two oh my god he's gonna fall into
the pit and turn to joki secure the area boys so oh make no
it's a woman butler So progressive.
Detective.
Let's go find those bears.
Because if they use goons and their kids, the kids would be
like, and the parents also would be like, how dare you?
This is what's wrong with society.
All right, here I go.
Wee!
Maybe a bear's been left behind in one of these countries.
All right, peekaboo.
Where's the other guy?
There you go.
Let's go around him.
All right, counter.
Oh, I- oh my god, wait, there's more?
I was like, I dodged it.
She didn't stop shooting.
That's like, shoot your own friend!
Oh, that's a lot.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
Wait, I wanna...
Let me throw my Badaran.
Badaran!
Badaran, Badaran!
Badaran, Badaran, Badaran!
That's right.
Veteran, Veteran, Veteran, Veteran, Veteran!
Veteran!
There we go.
Rock on!
Random bullshit!
Let's go!
Veteran, Veteran, Veteran, Veteran, Veteran!
The dorky bat went.
Let me TP 80 miles towards your body.
There we go.
Bataran.
I'm so cool.
Alright, where the fuck is the bear?
Must be here.
Something tells me there's a bear inside the container.
Hmm, I wonder if there's any bears here.
Time to identify this chemical.
Alright.
Let's play this.
And then...
Grab that.
And that.
There you go.
Analysis complete.
That's the first chemical identified.
Let's find the other two.
Alright, let's speedrun this.
Thank god the range is unlimited.
The range is yes.
Okay, who do I kill?
Oh.
Kill you first.
There you go.
I'm coming over.
Better run, better run, better run, better run.
Alright, grab the gun with the guy with the gun first.
Bro, he doesn't know.
Boop!
That's fucking right.
Get Lego'd!
Alright, let's get these guys out of here.
That's fucking right.
You encounter this?
I shoot your teammates!
That's our friendly fire!
Boom!
Who the fuck are you shooting at?
Oh, that's it.
I'm mad.
Give me a sec.
Let me punch these other people first.
Better, better, better, better, better.
Oh, wait, there's more.
I was taking it slow.
I was savoring that moment.
Alright.
You get out.
No more for you.
Don't worry.
We'll rebuild a new dad for your family.
Your kids won't even know the difference.
Or rebuild your family a new father figure.
And he'll be better than whatever you are.
all right nice that should be everybody and not the area
where the bear is oh my god there's still one more guy yep
very safe move it that's his fault I feel like the only job
you can get in Gotham City is just to be a goon honestly Oh,
hey, look, I have a car.
What do I do with this car?
I'm forklift certified.
Oh, is the bear in here?
Oh, it is.
Okay, I'll figure out how to get in there.
Oh, do you guys hear the new AI?
There's a, apparently, AI is paying people.
What was it?
some shit to to goon you guys hear about that there's
probably a beer left on the train two dollars per goon you
guys hear about that i do not know why but i missed it
missed what
what did i miss
wait but wait i'm doing it for free let me grab let me start
your final study if you were like the bubbles the bubbles
gonna pop soon all right we finally have a job oh never mind
adult ai company called joi ai is hiring a masturbation
consultant with a salary of two sorry not two dollars two
thousand dollars a month this position Mainly to test her
latest flagship daily guided masturbation feature.
Yes, yep, it's real.
Here you go.
Where can you apply?
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, it's 2P a month.
There's a form and everything.
And this looks like...
sign me so they make they're trying to they're trying to
make an AI guy a guy to take me I'll be suing for owed wages
and back pay for the past few decades thank god thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you so they're trying to
look for they're looking to pay 10 people $2,000 a month to
report the efforts of masturbation on sleep, stress, and
mood.
What is this AI even for?
To test an AI-guided masturbation feature with voice
scenarios and report how it affects stress, sleep, and mood.
And it's like guiding you on proper technique?
Like, what is the AI for?
What?
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My time has come unintended.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
I'll take half a salary if I can say my position is the good
lord.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You have huge competition.
They're only picking 10.
It's like the Willy Wonka golden ticket.
It's the Willy Wonka golden ticket.
You have fierce competition.
What differentiates you from the other?
Imagine to send a resume.
A resume on past experiences and references.
The Guna Limits.
Alright, one of the bears in here.
There it is.
What makes you a top candidate compared to the others?
all right let's analyze the chemical analyze this i come in
and this is the first thing i hear also i don't keep playing
thank you thank you thank you dang thank you the super chat
thank you thank you thank you thank you oh is that not it oh
is this oh i thought it was that oh is this
There we go.
Now this is complete.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just one more bear to analyze.
Drive this.
Analyze this.
He ain't making shampoo, that's for sure.
You don't know that.
Maybe it's like those masochist shampoo that stings, that
can kill you.
That's the thrill of it.
A shampoo that can kill you.
down there oh it's pretty toxic oh this has to be the bear I
can just stand here I don't think that I don't think the
game that's what the game wanted me to
do wait but what's over there though oh shit oh but what if
oh shit whoops I'm right?
I'm okay.
I guess I have to press these buttons.
No?
Why do I shut this down?
Is this not the place?
There must be a way to shut this down.
Oh my god, I forgot about Gordon.
Alright, Gordon.
It's time for you to shine.
Sorry, I forgot about his whole existence.
Is that it is?
Is that just money?
Oh, it was just money.
Is it really just money?
Alright.
This is Batman's game.
It says Batman Legacy, not Gordon Legacy.
Okay.
Time to find out what he's been storing in this bear.
Alright.
Whoops.
I don't even how we got to the topic about that ai how did
we even get to the topic about ai
all right
and i know it has to be this
you brought it yeah but how did we get here it was
unprompted i was talking about ai why was i talking about ai
You brought us here.
Copy that, Batman.
Let's move.
It came out of... Oh, gooning!
That's how it came from.
Here we gotta go.
This way.
Fun fact guys.
Well, you guys don't like my fun facts?
Alright, here we go.
Looks like we aren't going in the front door.
We need to identify another entry point.
Perhaps a window or a vent.
Like here?
Nice.
It's a good thing they didn't notice me.
We are all looking for the one responsible for this bed, but
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, boys, quick as you like.
Time to put the plan into action.
There's a plan?
Yeah, and where'd you want these?
Are you out of your minds?
Haven't I gone over this enough times?
We take one of these toys and another, mixed with one of
these.
That'll take a while, so here's one I made earlier.
Smiley.
Oh, my God.
It's a jungler gas.
He said the word!
Is he allowed to?
We're moving to manufacturing.
Pencil and a meeting with the mayor.
See what price he puts on the people of Gotham.
Keep it locked.
Oh my god, he said it!
You need to break up this picnic.
He's gooning!
Next thing, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Your fun facts are mostly about adult topics.
Oh, perform powerful attack.
Okay.
That's right.
Didn't expect this, did you?
Oh, I think he did expect that.
Don't worry.
I have one thing.
Roots are much more weaker while stunned.
Oh, I could just use your max combo.
There you go.
Done.
That's wrecked.
Bad round, bad round, bad round.
Oops!
Actually, bad round Gordon.
There we go.
Let's try quickly.
Bom, Bow, bow, bow, bow, bow, bow, bow, bow!
Bad round, batter, batter, and batter, batter, and batter,
and batter, and.
That's working, right.
You can dodge his attack next time.
What do you mean?
I literally just did that.
All right.
Yeah, you want to go hit me here?
That's right.
Gordon, any minute now, Gordon!
All right, nice.
Get finished.
Yeah!
He did it.
He's dropped the key for the elevator.
Come on.
Where does that taste?
Where is the elevator?
Where the fuck is the other?
Oh, it's over there.
No, that's a truck.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot it's the fucking floor.
It's a floor vader.
Alright, down we go.
I was just looking for the door.
Me thinking of five gifts and shifts, thinking, thinking.
Oh, he's not forklift certified.
Couldn't be me.
I would assume like this is like the only job you can get in
Gotham City There's like surprisingly a lot of goons here
I feel like that's the only way to like get by in Gotham
There's stuff over here
How do I get over here?
there I
don't think that's how I get here it's either you're a cop
or you're a goon oh I would assume like I wonder if there's
a union like if you're an employment agency and it's like
goon agency yeah
I got that out of the way yeah so you know, what happens
when your boss dies or, like, is in Arkham Asylum because of
Batman.
You gotta still be employed, you know?
You gotta still have to find another.
Gotta find another employer.
Gotta find another henchman.
Or gotta find another boss.
So I would assume, you know?
I would assume that you know, the agency relocates you to a
new... Because how do the How do the criminals find new
goons?
New goons to hire too.
Is it like a help wanted ad?
Is there help wanted ad and be like looking for new goons
for a new criminal boss?
Up and coming criminal boss?
Let's follow the pipes in the mixing room and shut this
place down.
Put a help wanted ad?
Whoa, what is going on?
What the fuck?
Speaking of goons, did you know a fan of Arsenal Football
Club currently Premier League?
Are called gooners?
Nice.
That's a good name.
Oh, I should have done that.
I just went in and walked behind them.
Germany, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow, now goons are unionized and got them for Amazon
employees.
Alright.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, even Joker believe in worker, right?
He ain't a monster.
Alright, wait, was there something over here?
There's a button here.
I want to press it.
I did it.
Right, but what does this go?
There must be stuff here.
I knew it.
I knew there was a secret.
Yeah, I mean, that's true.
The amount of times Batman has broken their bones.
You'd think they would have health insurance, you know?
Because why would you want to be a goon if you're just going
to get beat up anyway?
And you're going to take into the hospital.
They must have really good health insurance.
Like the Batman insurance.
They need to have good health benefits to deal with Batman.
oh what could it be right behind you if comments are to be
believed the henchmen apparently have union and trade
opportunities with each other and some goon even reviews
raid my raid my villain
that's what i'm saying i was like there must be like an
agency that relocates goons or some shit like what happens
if your villain gets put in arkham asylum what do you do i'm
gonna have Nick that's what I'm gonna do rate my villain um
one star um like the benefits are nice but like the costumes
uh you have to be a clown you have to always be a clown 24 7
and he makes you laugh at his jokes even though they're not
that funny uh no it's really raid my villain.
Like, raid my professor.
Yeah, Two-Face has a 50-50 approval on raid my villain.
And you don't laugh, he shoots you.
So, not really the best villain, but he's somehow always the
one that's out of Arkham Asylum that's always hiring.
So, what can you do?
If you really need a job, then I guess you gotta go with
Joker.
But there are better opportunities elsewhere.
All right, I want to grab that.
Wait, but there's a chest down there.
I want to grab that.
I mean, Mr. Freeze, all he does is just to help his dead
wife.
So I would assume he pays really well.
Because, like, he's not, like, really a villain by...
He's not really, like, a villain by choice.
he just wants to help his way so I assume he's like gotham
is changing and red hood one is just the beginning well I
guess like he has standards I'll get some use out of this
yeah and then mad hatter mad hat you know mad hatter pays
for pays for his reviews mad hatters uh rate my villain
review has to be botted or some shit.
Mr. Breeze is a great boss.
Surprisingly very chill.
He treats the employees to Taco Tuesday every week.
The Riddler makes you make you take IQ tests before you
work.
If you won't be employed by the Riddler, he's gonna make you
take an IQ test just to make... And you have to Solve his 10
riddles to be employed.
If you solve his 10 riddles, you get the job.
Also, he takes credit.
Also, he takes credits for all your cool riddles, too.
Yeah.
To pass...
Oh, wait.
The riddler's application is 100% capture.
Yeah, riddle me this.
Why should I hire you?
It's like the, what's it called?
Oh shit, whoops Whoops
All right, let's get this guy out of here
When you're when you have an interview with the Riddler,
it's like the It's like when you're applying for an engineer
For a coding job Oh my god, wait, I actually have to lock
in.
Give me a sec.
I got locked in on this kid's game.
Nice, I'm glad he had shot his buddy.
Alright, nice.
There we go.
God, that was too close.
I'm dying in this kid's game.
I'm dying on this children's game.
But it's like, what is it called?
The coding job?
We're coding jobs called, but it's just like that.
You know how you have to get on a...
They'll be like, how would you solve this coding problem?
And then, you ever see those videos where they rub like
Vaseline or some shit on the webcam and then have a chat GPT
on the side?
Yeah, software engineers, yeah.
yeah and then but to be and then Riddler does like those job
interviews and and the goons would just rub Vaseline on the
webcam oh wow Vaseline what is it what did they rub is it
not they rub like some lotion on it I thought it was
Vaseline they would rub like lotion in the webcam so it
would like like um so it would like enhance the the AI or
some shit or was it cream oh I didn't even have to do this
part I do have to do this part let me push this button wait
which way do I go there's two way oh this way it's just
money oh
it's basically like um oh nice it's basically how like
software engineers uh a lot of software engineers right now
are like super people who are hiring people that start
people that got hired to do like programming or software
engineering are so are super incompetent because they cheat
on their interviews because they would just like it would
just have like the ai program running in the background and
then the interviewer will give them like questions on how to
solve things and now the interviewer has to figure out if
they're reading if they're reading it from chat gpt or
something gonna be like the 2025 lex luther he's
insufferable already i don't want him as a tech bro speaking
of which have you seen a comic where he got into no i have
not seen the one where he got into crypto.
This is so much fun.
This stuff stinks way less than I expected.
They're having so much fun, guys.
Yeah, so they have to figure out if the person that they're
interviewing is using AI or not.
So they have to be like, so the interview will be like, wow,
that's a really good answer.
It feels like you're reading it off of a text.
book uh reading it off of a ai or something
like wow what a nice concise answer that you got there
what do you have oh wait
almost like it was written by a program oh
in a different way.
Can you summarize that in your own words?
Alright, yay.
And then...
This starts all the way over here in this room now.
Oh my god, he didn't come here with me.
I got the impatient.
Alright, let's go back.
I wonder which villain would be the best villain to work
for.
There's the machine.
Let's do this.
Oh.
Yeah, you work for Bane, you have to dope.
They do dooping tests, but it's to make sure that you are
doping.
They're like, how can...
If you're not on Venom, then you get fired.
committed to the cause.
You're not as committed.
Yeah.
He all passed the drug test by being on drugs.
You're not getting doped enough.
Alright.
Oh, there's... Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Oh, my God.
There's a dark source dodge.
Alright.
Oh, there's a batter at.
Oh.
Wait
You mean I could have thrown him into the pit the entire
time?
You tell when it locked something in me or not the
realization hits I was like wait this changes everything
Don't worry Batman doesn't kill
Am I supposed to Shut down the machine.
Is that the build?
I knew it.
I had to build.
It's time to build.
See, this is why Joker had rate my... Rate my villain
reviews are like one star.
This is exactly why.
I know.
I'm Batman.
That's me.
You too.
The way he talks reminds me of Jim Carrey.
Not like the boys, but like...
His...
His vocal...
His vocal tics.
Hold on.
The intonation, yeah.
This place is falling apart.
He wants to bring this whole place down.
We have to stop it.
Alright.
Oh, for lunch.
Back six?
Oh, the safety office.
Okay, that's a good one.
Hey, guys.
The lair might be out.
It might explode soon.
But don't worry.
I'll make sure you'll stay there when it explodes.
It's like a mix of Tom Kenny and Jim Carrey, the way he
speaks, the intonations.
It reminds me of their- it reminds me of their- the way they
speak.
Guess you'll never get- leave the lair.
Where do
I go?
Wee!
Oh, I just go for it.
Whee!
All right, I got build.
All right, keep building.
Keep building, Gordon.
All right, I'll grab this cash real quick.
That's how billionaire stays a billionaire.
Whee!
Oh, I have to wait for Gordon.
Gordon, please!
Oh, no.
No, Gordon bugged out.
Oh, no, now I'm up here.
Gordon, please.
Gordon!
Oh, my God.
He's fully bugged out.
Where is he going?
Gordon, where are you going?
Hey, where did he go?
Hey, where did Jerry go?
He was right there.
Oh.
Oh, I guess I have to kill them in here.
You know, you guys could escape.
But since you want to be here, that's fine.
That's on you.
Look, they chose to be here.
They chose to die.
They could have left.
But I'm Batman.
Look, Joker said anyone that kills Batman has an 80% bonus.
Can I cover the fire?
Why am I supposed to open that door?
Oh, I just threw...
Okay.
I just...
That's how.
That's just toxic, yes.
About what...
Oh.
But that...
Would that break this?
But there's money in there.
There's money in there, though.
But what?
about the money oh i just saw look up i already went through
the door i have a little something for you just a minute
please just bear with me it's uh no not that that's for
later it's in here somewhere whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo gamers never
look up a bazooka what would i do the whole of gotham will
have a permanent smile on its face What if I just...
It's alright, Batman's out of it.
Oh, I just have to dodge all of them.
Hello?
Oh, now it counts.
I guess running away doesn't count.
I was like, I did it, I ran away.
Alright, one more.
I wonder who invested in Jokers?
In like, invest in Joker's plans.
I wonder if he has investors, you know?
How did he get started?
How did he have...
What was his business plan?
To get all this funding for the lair, the hiring, the goons,
the technology.
You must have investors, right?
Imagine pitching this.
He's like, alright, this time.
Does he have a lucrative Polymark to do a Kickstarter?
Is he like a tech bro?
He's like in the one year you can get back your money and
more Was he a shark tank his old plan?
Somebody's sleeping in that office.
Oh My god, I was supposed to be beating up I was supposed to
be beating up the cars
Oh, it's right there
The insurance payout from the acid fat falls.
I knew I can't believe it.
The fucking cards.
It was the cards all along.
Oh, there's like special villain investors.
I don't think this place could take much more.
What does agencies call that help you invest stuff?
And you don't have to look at investing yourself.
You just hire an agent.
agency to do it for you.
I wonder if there's that, but for villains.
Wasn't Joker's new...
Oh my god, did they make her a hot tub streamer now?
She used to be just a college student.
Goodbye.
Good job, you're not scared of heights.
Yeah, believe it or not, it was never a problem before I met
you.
Hey, what's over here?
What's that hedge fund oh shit goodbye whoops wait wait wait
give me a sec here I fix the water now you can't hate me I
literally gave us an escape all
right oh nice out
of this all right let's go down here
oh oh shit oh shit whoops round one all right one two
ow oh my god i'm trying to get on this
that's crazy that is new girlfriend is now I didn't realize
how far I went all I knew about it was the fact that she was
a college student I
did read the car debut comic it's it's yeah that's all I'll
say he's just super Like her...
Her as a character is just...
Being edgy.
That's really it.
I don't know how else to describe it.
This new girlfriend.
She's just...
She's like...
She's basically just like Joker's number one fan girl.
So she wanted to be like him.
And then she like killed her professor or some shit.
Smiles really are infectious.
Are they...
Yeah.
So why did she become a hot tub streamer?
What?
Where did that come from?
What happened to Harley?
She's gay now.
Well, not like now now, but it's been a while.
And she's with Ivy now.
She's more like an anti-hero.
More by.
She's by now.
Yeah, she's more by, I think, right?
But yeah, now.
Now she's like with Ivy.
And she's more like it.
She's ridden more like an anti-hero.
Like she's ridden more like Deadpool, basically.
So like sometimes she's super evil and then sometimes she's
a hero.
Oh, did they broke up?
Don't worry, they'll get back together.
Ivy is the mayor of Gotham now?
What the fuck?
It's like hiring...
It's like hiring like Ted Bundy.
As your new mayor.
He's like, yeah, I might have killed a bunch of people.
A lot has happened.
That's why.
He's like, yeah, I killed a lot of people.
And, yeah, I cost millions of dollars a debt to Gotham City
with all the destruction around the city.
Yeah, I might have robbed the bank several times.
And turned some of your loved ones.
ones into uh into plants but vote for me is a vote for a
better gotham
oh yeah that's true that's true that could be like yeah but
it's got the city who hasn't killed a lot of people that's
true i love her environment policy policies though she might
have killed a lot of people I love her environment policies!
It's a vote for a greener Gotham.
How many diamonds has died so many times?
Also like Rob, apparently, also in one universe, Robin hooks
up with Harley Quinn.
Or Nightwing hooks up with Harley Quinn.
bat of acid goodbye this is where he falls down i created
you give me your head
what if i don't come on come on oh whoa whoa whoa whoa that
mike whoa oh you're hanging on there for too long that's
true who hasn't he got hooked up with There was a clip of
it, but basically Harley tied, I saw, well I saw, it was
like Batman and Harley Quinn animated movie.
And basically like Nightwing, Harley Quinn kidnapped
Nightwing, tied him up.
And then she was like taking off her clothes.
And then Nightwing was like, whoa!
And then, you know, and then obviously he's in a skin tight
superhero costume.
And then Harley Quinn was like, whoa, you excited, little
boy?
Are you excited?
And then they hooked up.
yeah that that's basically that's basically the the gist of
it okay and then batman came in well obviously after the
deed was done a little boy one they're all grown up and then
batman came in and then um she saw he saw he saw the
underwear on the floor and he was like hmm
as if you haven't hooked up with any of the villains and
then he's just like did you find him
hey batman was very disappointed anyway grab my hand joker
but what if i don't oh no i'm straining so high to lip whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh that's your pull-up one two three four oh my god he got
closer why is he barking five just doing my reps hey no no
all right he's eight he ate at four so he doesn't he can't
eat again all right six
he's gonna die anyway like like will not die like it's it's
written in his story it's canon why are you nuts it's a man
he has to fall anyway why give me this bullshit way it's a
cannon event i should be allowed to just throw him into the
bat what is this detective you guys pals or something no
we're just friends i mean we're just you know we're just
acquaintances Oh, there he is.
Now he's white.
It's complicated.
Yeah, just work buddies.
Oh, what the fuck?
Skeleton, Gordon.
Alright.
What happened?
He's fine, right?
Batman never kills.
Exactly.
It was a bad, I tell you.
Yeah, yeah, that's what they all say.
Why do we always have to meet so high up, huh?
Guess I like the view.
The Commissioner thinks you're dangerous.
What do you think?
I think you're trying to help.
I've got something for you.
Not sure what the other cops will say, but I put it on top
of the GCPD.
Let's head to Trichorne.
when you're ready.
Wait, let's...
I want to change...
Wait.
How do I change the suit again?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, what's my new suit?
I have...
The dark...
Oh, zero year.
Time to start a very big another universe reboot.
And look, the purple gloves are back.
Batman Zero years collection of story arcs.
Oh, that's cool.
Which one have I used already?
I did...
All right, let's get Dark Knight Returns.
Let's try Zero, yeah.
Oh, my God.
But look at him.
He's so edgy.
Oh, is that the new fit?
There's so many news.
I want him to be Skelly.
Skelly Gordon.
All right.
Look at us, go.
Look at us.
Me and my very much alive friend.
Oh, am I going back home?
Go to GCDP on Tri Corner.
All right.
I feel like...
See, do I need a fast travel that?
Where is it?
Where am I?
Okay, I'm right here.
And I have a fast travel and I do.
Where the fuck did that take me?
Oh, it's over here.
We're right here.
Oh,
I get in there.
Should be like, yeah?
Don't worry, I'm Bruce Wayne.
I can just rebuild the city.
Where's the door?
Where the...
Oh, it's up there.
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll just write a blank check and everything will be
forgiven.
given the fuck do I get in here oh up top maybe all right
there we go I'm here now all right let me reassemble this
all right assembly required oh it's a bad signal Let's go!
Used with Gotham's tax dollars.
Taxes must be, like, super cheap in Gotham City.
Or not.
Actually, no, it can't be.
Actually, yeah, because, like, what are we funding?
This is basically the yearly expenses.
One bad signal.
This is their...
This year's full budget.
That's their entire budget.
Bruce Wayne wouldn't know.
That's true.
Yeah, but what are they paying for?
Clearly the cops aren't doing...
Oh, it's that!
It's that cat woman!
Oh, he's okay.
Oh.
There's Danny the Vito, penguin.
Yeah, Danny Elfman, yeah.
That is...
Alright.
I mean, that's true.
Who would use that as the elevator?
Okay.
Oh.
Small boo-boo, total repit-bait boo-boo.
Oh, there's the jocular.
When did you get a load of me?
Nice.
That cave has come a long way, Alfred.
But we still have work to do.
It certainly has, Master Bruce.
Oh, look at my beautiful bad cave.
I'm just thinking, like, don't I have to hire contractors to
make the bad cave?
Like, what the fuck?
What do I tell them?
There's no way that the butler made all of this.
Yeah, but what do I?
They're like, oh, it's weird that you're...
Oh, Maybe they hire, like, people who do, like, villain
hench, like, lairs, and they're like, yeah, I'm the next
up-and-coming villain.
I don't want to make you make me a cave in...
Make me a lair in the cave.
And...
But then, like, don't they be like, why is your lair
underneath Bruce Wayne's mansion?
Wouldn't that be something to ask about?
Oh, there's the Riddler.
Really?
Oh my god, I'm doxing the Riddler.
And there was another kit here.
Alright, we got another mini-kit.
Oh, we...
I improved the back cave.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, they would have to sign an NDA.
Oh, yeah, I have a lot of money.
Expand it.
Oh, oh, or he could be like, or Bruce Wayne wants to create
like, oh, he's a spare, start my spare suit.
Oh, this is where I store it.
He's just like, I'm a really big fan of Batman.
He please build me a, uh, my man cave.
This is my man cave and I'm Batman's number one fan.
That also works.
Oh, that's Gordon.
Why am I at Gordon's stuff here?
What's in here?
I'm totally not Batman.
I'm just...
I'm just a really, really big fan of him.
This is my man cave.
Alright.
Try out for the other stuff.
What's this?
It's just...
his hobby, guys.
He just likes collecting Batman memorabilia.
I wonder if the Justice League has merch.
You know?
They must.
I mean, it's Batman.
He must have.
What's it called?
Trademarked the Justice League.
Probably, yeah.
You would think so, right?
It's Batman.
He should see the capitalism potential of of making merch
Yeah, in universe Looks like it's operational Let's get
started Where's my Oh, wait, there's stuff here
Just the kind of tech I need Yeah, he must have done
merchandising He must have sold out How else is he going to
get the funding to build the Justice League Space Layer?
Where is O is here?
She can hold different props.
What?
Oh, I have to delete it.
Yeah, the watchtower.
Oh!
Oh, that's cool.
I'm going to have this, obviously.
Obviously, we're up in my little garage band.
And then...
What else?
Oh, it's Joker TV!
Yeah, that's remarkable.
Oh, and then a dance floor for people to rock out while I'm
playing my sick-ass tunes.
Imagine the acoustic.
Yeah, pimp my layer.
And then...
Where are all of these?
Blue Prince Crane?
Where are my weights that can work up?
I put some balloons.
There we go.
There we are.
Pimp my layer.
Look at that.
It's not who I am underneath.
But how I shred that defines me.
That's fucking right, Alfred!
It's rock out!
My parents are dead.
Yeah!
I'll be here all night.
Now dance.
Okay, dance.
Oh my god, wait, I can rock out and dance.
Oh my god, go, Alfred, go.
Bad metal is real.
Wait, I know you can dance with Batman.
Alright.
Someone told me to put it in the doghouse.
Oh, does the dog come out of here?
Does my bad dog come out?
Bad dog!
Get... Oh my god, there he is!
Good boy!
Who's a good bad dog?
You're a good bad dog.
What other stuff do I have, actually?
Really, the other stuff aren't as cool.
Mel's throwing the lava lamp, the giant bomb.
Oh, I guess I could play sock.
Wait, why her baby what does the bait who's in the baby crib
who's in here gotta support the huh what the fuck is the
whole thing is ahead whose baby is this who the fuck's baby
is this that's not it's not him that's not the baby i made
with talia i assume like
Assume that it's just a TV that turns on.
Alright, nice.
There's a dead man.
There's no way that's Robin.
There's no, not just Robin.
There's no way that's Damian or Robin.
Whose kid is this?
Alright, we gotta go to the next wrench.
It's so far.
Oh wait.
Okay, there's...
Never mind.
It's right here.
Oh, I build.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, $10.
Oh, here I can buy more.
Okay, I have so much money.
Oh, my gosh.
Batman and Robin.
Batman 66.
Wait, Batman versus Superman?
I want to get the Batman.
mana rob can i buy skins too i wonder where's the skins is
it here or is it just for display purpose oh it's just for
display purposes oh wait i missed that out
don't worry guys i made back the money already in 10 seconds
oh not right now okay all right because i think i spent a
lot I might have just bought all the cars.
Just casually buying all the cars.
There's a little side project I've been meaning to show you.
Shall we find a battery for it, sir?
Found it.
Yeah, Alfred, let me carry this for you.
Even though I pay you to be my butler.
I present to you the challenge board.
Challenge board.
When you hit certain criteria out in the field, more of the
mural can be be revealed something else to help motivate you
other than avenging your parents obviously he's an old man
joe here yeah that can rock out all right surfer shredder oh
i got that
distract tent enemies using quick hacks oh oh my god it's
like a powerpuff girls phone is ringing master bruce i doubt
it's a telemarketer using objects from the environment oh
what i think that's how you rip stuff oh my god the mayor
the mayor of gotham is calling me bat phone mushy mushy it's
bat might come on that might's in here is that what is that
He's like the comic relief.
He was like Plastic Man.
But then like Plastic Man is actually a better character.
Where is he?
He wanted me to do a Batman.
He's like the scrappy do, I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah, sort of.
He's like sort of the scrappy do of Batman.
I know we have something to take out this wall just have to
find it I believe something was delivered that could aid us
here perhaps I should have created over here oh
yeah this is perfect all right oh
my god oh it's a spray oh I can't draw it.
Unlucky.
I can't draw it myself.
Cool, guys.
Don't look at explosions.
Whoa!
I mean, uh, successfully cleared.
Yeah, I'm so cool.
An explosive spray.
Oh, I told you guys!
Oh, it's the Batmite store.
It's not even me.
Oh, he bought my trademark, guys.
He bought my licensing.
Fabmite owns the Batman license?
Well, not the Batman.
I'm told it in a medium, but...
Sorry.
Hang on.
Batman's super bad.
I really wanted to be in the game, so I had to find some way
to slide in.
Need me to put myself in the shopkeeper.
Can't be on with this one.
This is copyright infringement.
I got props.
All that bad stuff you could want.
What do I want, though?
Why do I have to pay?
Bro, this is me.
Why am I paying money to buy it?
Oh, wait.
That's me when I buy my own merch.
Never mind.
I understand your game, Batman.
Herbal T-set.
Alfred serves T-Injustice.
What does he do with that?
Pirate costume.
Oh, my God.
I could be a pirate.
Wait, I want to be a pirate.
Oh, boy.
First sale completed.
I'm going to frame this.
That's fish crate cabbage planter.
I can start gardening What's this?
Oh, it's just upgrades.
Oh, I have enough Fling enemies away with the bat cloud
allows Batman to slam an enemy down And oh wait, that's so
convenient Pull speed Pull strength of bat cloud to gank
larger enemies increases impact deal with an enemy It's
thrown at another enemy but i should like that this would be
so convenient
like how would they know
deal extra damage
surely yeah we'll just do that for now
buy bad key i could do that but i could also buy i could
also buy new outfits though I could be a...
Look, guys.
I could be a pirate.
Wait, what costume is...
Oh, Alfred.
Alfred doesn't have costumes?
Why I could be a pirate, guys?
Bench.
There's a stop sign.
Oh, is that it?
Leave the shop, okay.
I got some shops opening up in Gotham, by the way.
All right.
Well, it seems like I have to make a cease and descece
again.
All right.
Yeah, no macaroni costume for Alfred.
Oh my God, it's a Joker.
Everything okay, sir?
You look like you've seen a ghost.
Oh my.
All right, I'm going to eat the rest of my...
Oh, this is the tortilla.
I ate the taco.
Now I got the tortilla.
My corn asada.
Carnasada?
My carnasada.
Where is your sauce?
Taco Tuesday.
All right, let me put my...
onions um well we watch our clutch scene Harvey you okay I'm
gonna invite me to this party oh my god Harvey
he fired him what's in the cup water it stains we ate some
lemon juice salt and just a touch of jelly someone quick
help him he's
gonna be fine guys
he's so healthy guys don't worry truly nothing bad is gonna
happen to harvey what an upstanding citizen are you okay
We can't let them get away.
No way he's gonna become a villain or anything.
This bad sister in expats all over town.
Let's track them down.
Someone needs to take them.
Oh shit.
I can do this with one hand.
They're driving for me.
There we go.
Alright.
easy
I'm doing it back of events exposed time to look at that L1
oh all right we'll wait here oh shit what oh fuck okay he'll
drive back truly come back right
they'll come back no worries losing those vans is not an
action don't come back
yeah don't worry they'll come back it's truly a loop over
they won't come back
hmm No.
Those mines need to be stopped.
Don't worry.
See, stop!
Just stop!
Wait.
I want you.
Okay.
Can't let those no good mines escape.
It stops after you.
See, I told you.
I'm not allowed
to decide anymore.
See?
All right.
Almost done.
Look, the fat man doesn't want to eat and drive.
It's dangerous.
I told you guys to come back see all I have to do is go this
way and then I pull them I told you he loops guys I told you
there we go I told you he loops leaving the vehicle would be
a bad idea Oh, I had to stop another one.
All right.
Don't worry, Gotham City.
Your hero is here.
We don't have a problem here, do we?
Do not worry, Gotham.
All right.
Keep blasting.
And I kept blasting.
Whoops.
And then I kept blasting.
Listen, where is he gonna go?
Oh, now you want to write a ticket.
Now to deal with the other one.
See, look at that.
See, they came to me, guys.
Look at that.
Easy.
Go to the car dealership.
Where's that?
Oh, it's over there.
Hello, everybody.
I'm legally allowed to drive on a sidewalk because I'm
Batman.
And in the stairs.
Because I have a license.
I have the pass.
Look, see?
Bruce Wayne Graves.
Grants me in unity.
But that my best friend.
My best friend Bruce Wynn says it's okay.
Alright.
Those mimes are probably hiding around here somewhere.
Where would it be hiding?
In the phone?
A few of these vehicles seem kind of familiar.
They look like they could use a good clean.
They're gonna clean it.
There's something nearby that can help with that.
No, that's just money.
Oh my god, I swear to God.
Am I going to be building?
But I need a build.
I need a build.
It's building time.
No relations whatsoever.
He's just my best friend.
He used to be roommates in college.
Me and Bruce Wayne.
Oh.
How do I use it?
That's my grappling hook.
I should keep looking in this area until I find what I need.
And not...
Oh, okay.
I just have to get on it.
Oh.
Oh, I don't have water anymore.
What does this plug into?
Oh, here.
Whoops.
I thought that was the hose at first.
Alright.
It doesn't look like one of the fans we been chasing baker
maybe it's the third bad it's always the third bad mind your
own business
it's really hard to find a goon that has mining experience
too
mines don't pay what can i say
One more, I've got him.
I just need one more shot.
Oh, nope.
That's it.
Last shot.
So much for a clean getaway.
Morning, audience.
Mind sighted and restricted constable.
Criminal activity reported, but might be worth checking out.
What could those minds be doing in Trent's?
store all right time to go there
see now i'm such a safe driving look at that following
traffic laws it's like this way where is it it's that oh hey
what's that over there whose car is that oh it's just to
destroy
all right this way no where the fuck how do I get there all
right oh yeah it was a special elective in Goon University
thank God they have extra their special electives there
there's Shrek store oh and look another mine right up front
let's find out what's going on what leaving the vehicle
would be a bad idea all right what's going on talk who do
you work for
ah we haven't got time for this mime nonsense hang on I'm
good at these now that's more like it okay something about a
car no no truck speeding tortoise oh no Oh, I should have
stayed on Broadway.
I hope the tragedy.
Look at that.
Went to New York City, and now he's in Gotham.
Catwoman!
That's my other girlfriend.
Meow.
You won't...
Won't be needing that.
No!
You get after her, and I...
You're already gone.
Ah, shut up.
Yeah, she's new at this, guys.
It's her first day.
She hasn't got her backflips yet.
Look, see, she's working up hey watch out aren't you minds
meant to be silent i'm not with them and i'm guessing
neither are you who are you oh who's the man behind the mask
oh oh he's yeah he's like woman each other
sorry bad boy i work alone
he doesn't know what to do when a woman talks to him on
second thought maybe i could do with the extra muscle
i am cat woman hear me raw allow me unscrew a whip is useful
to unscrew and spin objects whatcha door is still closed
maybe i can use my whip on the spool as well not bad i know
damn i wonder what this guy's hidden behind here we're gonna
have to find an unconventional way out of here you okay so
it's cat heads looking course it's cat heads
all right keep an eye out i'm sure we can get one of these
doors open Yeah, I gotta keep going.
What is this place?
All right, if I keep whipping.
Whoops, I whipped too high.
There you go.
It locked up because I kept whipping.
to a secret entrance to my lair it's uh themed yeah and
that's that's really cool you know people say it's really
really cool yeah all the ladies love it you want you want to
head to my back cave later today i mean it's not i mean my
other friends will be there too you're not gonna be the only
one there it's not a date or anything it's just a hangout
and then she and then she comes there he's like oh i'm so
sorry all the they all cancel they just all couldn't make it
i'm some real performance art this is gonna be you you and
me i guess
oh man such a shame i planned this entire party for everyone
oh what are we gonna do now that's just us two there's no
way we can play two man twister unless you still want to
Catwoman.
I spent so much time planning this too.
And I rented a jacuzzi and everything.
It would be such a waste if we don't use it.
I mean, I already rented it.
We might as well.
Can I whip the camera?
Hachah!
Oh, I can.
Damn, the pool says no clothes.
Well, we don't want to break the law, do we?
Or it should be like, the pool says you have to keep your
clothes on when you're in the pool.
And, you know what?
You don't like falling rules.
do you cat woman did i kill him
oh i didn't see any stairs up here or anywhere let's take
the elevator
all right wait i'm gonna see what's over here okay that's
just
oh okay acha acha whoa
I'm trying to see how I can stealth this.
I mean, I feel like I bought that upgrade where I can grab
people, right?
Oh, shit, do you think they know?
There we go.
Boom!
Oh, shit, I really want to grab him and then chuck him.
That's right.
And I'll do it again.
Oh my god, oh shit, sorry, Selena!
Alright, and I grab him again.
And then, chuck!
Alright, let's get out of here.
I made this fight longer than it should be.
Now I ain't playing.
I actually wanna...
Whip, whip, whip, whip, whip.
That's looking right.
Spin!
Let it whip!
It's looking right.
Oh my god, you two, Batman!
Oh shit.
Alright, get pied.
Can he die from this?
I don't think so.
I can- Oh, nope, he can.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, I broke him in half.
Whip.
fight so you can die from it uh bad guy i thought we had to
hurry oh he's dead dead yeah i think he's pretty much dead
oh there was a key over oh well it's too late i guess we go
down
ah are they gonna be okay oh the cats should be fine
all right Batman time to tag the wall come on that boy get
us moving again it's that man I'm so cool all right
yay it's like a roller coaster put your hands in the air it
looks like we're going faster I thought cats always landed
on their feet oh shush There's a knife at this.
Don't worry.
I'll take care of that vent.
Whoops.
I think it's time I called in a...
We have an idea.
Oh, cats can enter.
Well, not that.
That was not my idea.
Also, apparently I found out.
Because I was wondering if, like, dogs also, like, laser
pointers.
Apparently, it's really bad for dogs because they couldn't
understand that because they get like super frustrated and
it actually gives them ADHD.
If you use laser pointers to play with your dog, it's really
bad because you can develop ADHD with it.
A band of highly trained feline companions that can complete
covert operations.
You should never use laser pointers with dogs.
Yeah, they get, like, super frustrated and, like, be like,
where the fuck's the lazy?
So you should never use laser printers on dogs.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
Okay, he needs to know when he can eat.
Yeah.
really mad and frustrated being like, where the fuck's my
laser pointer?
No, I didn't slap him.
I just hit the wall.
I just did that.
He'd be like, no.
No, I did that and I clapped.
I did this.
He'd be like, no!
So he understands.
Because it works.
Every time I do that, like, I look at him and I clap, I'm
like, no!
And then he walks away.
Okay.
looks like an ambush definitely an ambush all right let's
see if i can do this let me see try this again
but how did he know with you would get boring wait how did
he know i hear more coming what the fuck why do mines have
fucking guns okay
if i just throw that ow that's fine i just throw it against
the All right, if I throw this...
Kobe.
There we go.
It's easy.
Wait, I can throw him against the wall.
Okay, apparently I can't...
Oh, my god, it's like bowling!
Okay, apparently I can't really aim this.
Oh, there's more.
I don't even know how to aim this, honestly.
All right, who threw that?
Who threw that?
I wish I could aim the throws.
That's it.
All right, look at how much fun they're having though.
Double kill.
Hello, sir.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, no, no, not that.
Watch this.
And then...
Wait.
No!
He's not supposed to die!
I was gonna whip him and then batter at him.
It would be so cool.
Oh, there it is.
Cha, hacha, hacha.
Cha, hacha.
I need to send a cat.
Go, cat, go.
Wee!
Meow.
Looks like your cat hit a roadblock.
I'm a cat.
She's so cool.
Now watch me press this button.
All right, you stay here.
And then And then I leave and then watch this.
And then.
Veteran!
Whoops.
And then where do I throw you against?
There you go.
See, look at that.
Nothing else around.
Must be near that sign.
Just need a way up.
The combo.
The big sign.
But how do I take it down?
It's a dance dance time?
Oh, you did?
Maybe I have time for this game.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm the cat.
And I go that way.
Okay, now that I know skins are expensive.
I actually have to pick up money.
Oh, that kills me?
Is that dog?
I thought it was like a cat, a pig or something.
I don't know.
Cat beats pig.
Oops.
Okay.
Grab the money.
then we go straight in yay we did it nice oh wait I should
be able to upgrade stuff now right yeah I have two uh
increased health dive while gliding dealing damage launch
while in vehicle to eject high into the uh no that's not
good I don't know actually oh maybe jet focus
I don't get the focus
I feel like I have to whip that there you go now that's an
entrance with panache
all right okay now we actually fight we need to work
together here really guess we'll find out all right oh
he doesn't know oh he's so stupid
okay there you go oh he doesn't know what happened what
happened to that man oh guess we'll never know.
I guess we'll never know.
Stealth 100.
Look, it's very hard to find a goon who also has mining
experience.
Guys, Joker has to take what he can get.
Oh, and they're all guys.
Where do you find this mini mine must have been the win
exactly see I Find ones that can fight and mine I just love
a big strong man who's not afraid to show it but someone
yeah Oh tab All right All right Spill up my focus here
That's right the bad might take the little guy.
Oh my god in between your legs whoa in between your legs
again oh shit never mind whoa it's looking right whoa and
then combo there
we go nice got you what just start whipping that's Try
infinite combos!
Yeah, fuck that particular box too.
Easy.
Oh shit, never mind.
Alright, let's grab him.
Wait, jump.
What do you mean, jump?
Why does it keep making me jump?
Why does he keep making me jump?
What the fuck?
Yeah, what's that?
Why jump?
What if he died?
I'm so confused why it keeps making me jump.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, now it's like you don't need to jump anymore.
Oh yeah, fuck that guy.
Oh shit, I thought I avoided it.
I thought I'd touch that.
Jesus Christ, he's so fucking tanky.
There we go.
Oh my god, jackdabbered him.
Give me your heart.
hey but what's over here yeah
oh oh whoops wait oh I broke it
wait I broke it what
oh no I broke it I did it too many times I did it too many
times there
yeah yeah but last time it let me do it while it was playing
a new toy huh so maybe i broke it before yeah yippee
what's this spin all right okay but the first time we did it
let me do it even when it was playing so i thought i could
do it all the time Oh, look, it's the dinosaur.
Mimasan.
Konnichiwa.
Let's go.
One of those displays will help us smash those doors open.
Which one?
Balloons?
Oh, I can drive.
Oh my god, it's a mini Batmobile!
Where are we smashing?
Oh, do they mean we need to find another way in?
Oh, do they mean it?
like smash as in as in smashing that where there's a lock
there's a key keep looking so we smash the prize first don't
leave any block unturned
where is the key or smashing me smash everything I swear to
god there can't be that one key oh my god wait what is it
with max and locking up the Fun stuff.
Let's find that key.
The key's right there, but how do I smash that?
Oh, what?
All we need to get through that door is in here.
I know it.
In here?
Oh, in here!
Hello?
Got some stuff to smash.
Wait, what's in here?
I'm missing something in here?
Is it like a little Easter?
Oh, no!
No!
I couldn't bleed on it, but I started slashing!
I started slashing!
Alright, kitty.
Okay.
looking for an office key do your best is she really gonna
be able to find it on her own i did it she's very capable
even gets her own dinner all right i just want to keep
smashing i just want to smash
why give me all of this when i just when i I have
so much stuff to smash.
All right.
You're gonna help out Batman?
No?
All right.
Equal rights, I guess.
Equal rights.
Nice.
Oh, there's another cat.
Is that cat head?
No, it's just more smash.
all right we go this way that was not the thing i had to
smash apparently
anything else to smash here
i smashed so many things what else have i not smashed
smash must be missing something
Oh, there's a vent.
Oh, I see it.
Alright, kitty cat.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, nice.
Oh, sounds like my pretty kitty's got something nifty.
Oh my god, look at him.
Look at me.
Maw.
Okay,
here we go.
There you go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Is she okay?
Why is she so mad?
Your whip should provide enough momentum to
whip.
All right.
Nice.
What did I got from that?
Batman angry.
Oh, it's just more building.
Oh my god, we're gonna rock!
It's so hard to see that as a cat door suddenly.
has it does not look like a cat door all right time to rock
out this could destroy just about anything needs two
frequencies though rockin
let's rock
Let's go.
Boy,
it's getting faster.
How would the kids do this?
How would the kids have the hand-eye coordination?
That's right.
Come on, do it.
Not rock and run.
The solo.
Later solo this.
You hear about that kid?
It was like this little kid that beat up adults in combo
breaker and street fighter.
And someone like quote retweeted and was like, if that
happened to me, I would just quit street fighter forever.
Why not, buddy?
We have a date at the zoo.
It was this little kid on classic controls.
Need to drop in on an old friend.
The 10-year-old.
The 10-year-old kid that was like beating up adults who were
on modern controllers.
Yeah, he was like 10.
Is that how he just looks?
Hey, no.
I'll give him a little bit.
Alright.
Give him a little bit.
Because he's been pretty bratty.
Well, yeah, let me see if I can find a video.
That's actually pretty impressive.
A little 10-year-old kid.
10-year-old.
10-year-old combo breaker.
I think it was that combo breaker, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, his name is The Baby.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot.
His name is The Baby.
212.
That's his name.
The baby.
It's crazy.
What a great name.
The baby.
Alright, let me go back.
Yay.
Ooh, I got retro Batman.
That kid was crazy.
Yeah, he was on Classic, too.
this old friend you believe they're behind the mime attacks
you'll have to wait i want to change my outfit i'll be retro
batman you guys hear about the convention where oh where's
oh there it is i'm sorry batman returns we gotta go damn
they gave her boobs
I mean, obviously.
I mean, she's catwoman.
But, damn!
They had to highlight it.
You guys hear about ParkCon?
The FandoméCon, like, after party?
And the people were selling Fetu?
Fetu?
I thought I went, oh, I didn't confirm it.
Oh, I did.
Alright, we're flat.
The what?
Okay, so basically, for those who don't have a fucked up
algorithm like me, um, what happened was...
God, it's so far.
Can I make it?
I think I can make it.
So...
Basically, cosplayers, uh, were selling feet juice.
Now, what is feet juice, you might add?
Um, is basically, they get a water cooler fill it with juice
and then the cosplayer puts their feet in the juice and then
they sell it for like five to twenty dollars per swig
depending on how many swigs you want and the cosplays was
that girl from was it um was miku hasune and uh who was the
who was the other girl What was the other?
Yeah, the pictures and videos were pretty or something.
God, that's gross.
Apparently, they made $1,000 plus dollars in one day.
Oh, yeah.
Rap, yeah, from Niki.
I was going to say, I think it was the Niki girl.
So one was the Niki girl.
And then the other one was, you know, get your bag.
Get your bag.
And there was this whole discourse.
And people were like, yeah, we're talking.
Kaku culture has always been this degenerate.
It's not new, but I'm just like, what?
Feet juice?
It's still...
A bespector is gonna have an animatronic service.
It's so...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have the tweet.
Shall I link it?
Ha!
I'm gonna do it.
If I had to see it, you guys have to do it too.
Honestly, if I had to see it, I bookmarked it just for this
special occasion.
I...
There you go.
If I had to see it, you have to as well.
We all have to suffer through this together as a team.
We are a team, guys.
Just so we are a team.
It's too late.
Oh, yeah.
So, there you go.
Or a chance is being from an old...
Well, the thing is, they're dunking it live.
So I don't think, guys, I don't think it's, you know...
I don't think it's...
I think you can all see that it is happening live.
So yeah.
Um.
Yeah.
There's that.
There is that.
Anyway.
Back to Batman.
They made a thousand dollars though.
Where is she?
Oh shit, and she's alive?
Look, all I'm saying, if I had to see it, sharing is caring.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the rescue.
The animals have gotten out.
Well, it's like five to fifteen dollars per swig.
imagine how many people might have spent that in a day if
they have reached that if they made a thousand dollars in a
day just like look the map the map is a little scary awesome
yeah yeah that's a lot I
Let's save him.
I don't need to help another character.
I'll get past an obstacle to solve a puzzle.
Hold it.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I need Gordon, obviously.
Maybe it wasn't done live.
Who would be the expert that would say, wait a minute.
Something isn't right.
Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Someone who's very into B.
Great!
Now to figure out how to get the animals back.
What's this?
Here's the plan.
You put this tracker on the animals that escaped.
Then we'll know where they are and we can pick them up.
Easy peasy, right?
That sounds easy.
Oh, by the way, there's a loose polar bear nearby.
Think you can put a tracker on it?
Well, it's been there for a couple of hours.
What do you think, Mr. Broken Bond?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you think?
A water cooler can only do so much.
Put pigeons in the zoo?
It's like that zoo that had a dog, and then they painted it
black and white, and was like, that's a polar bear.
Or like, that's a panda.
There's the bear.
Let's get that tracker.
Do you see that article?
Did I beat him up?
How do I put the tracker on him?
That's one angry bear.
Maybe we should have...
I don't know where the tracker is!
How do I put the tracker?
Basically what they did, there was a zoo that painted a dog,
the giant dog, black and white, and then be like, Here's a
panda.
I put tracker on him.
He didn't give me the instructions.
How am I supposed to give him a tracker?
He just...
They didn't even give me the instructions on how to do it.
Oh, there we go.
I have to sneak up on him.
Oh, that makes more sense.
Tracker's up and running.
There, he's happy now, right?
all right now he's happy if you find any animals in the city
can you put a tracker on them we'll pick him up and rehome
him i don't understand how they all got out everything was
fine then the power was suddenly redirected to arctic world
was this mr freeze i'll get the maintenance hatch open in
case you want to check things out all right this is where mr
freeze comes out That place down months ago.
We should check it out.
Mr. Fweez.
Oh, I need to be Catwoman.
Sorry, Gordon.
It's woman only.
You don't have to nail us for it, Gordon.
Or penguin.
That's true.
It could be Penguin.
Oh, yep.
There's the penguins.
That's called foreshadowing, guys.
Hacha.
So why are we here?
I don't see any sign of those mimes.
This was Penguin's hangout before he started running for
mayor.
pot but he was just attacked at City Hall that slime ball
probably staged the whole thing I just know he's got my loot
loot hmm sorry my hard-earned loot she worked so high for it
sure on cash though call it feline intuition that slippery
Sleeve's bag is definitely in charge of those mimes.
Oh, secret camera.
That'll be my pizzas.
They better not have scrimped on the enemies.
Looks like we'll have to bypass the security gate to get
inside.
Leave it to me.
These claws aren't just for show.
But...
Grab some money real quick.
The hard-earned money.
Oh, it's being used all night.
As penguins must be a little layer.
Alright, nice.
For all the money I need.
But what?
Hacha, hacha.
The penguin really thinks putting the override switch up
there would stop me.
Do you guys know how wildfire...
Oh my god, I just recently fired up.
I'm sorry.
noticed that while I was looking at Catwoman, you know
Wildfire from the Lego movie?
I never realized those were boobs.
Like her hips and stuff.
Is it Wildfire?
What's her name?
Lego Movie Girl.
Okay, so like I never realized her hips.
Yeah, Wildstyle.
Sorry.
Okay, I need to show you guys because that blew my mind
because in my head I just I couldn't it didn't like click in
my head that she is like built Like an hourglass figure like
she had an hourglass figure basically.
She was like wow So I've just recently I was recently
noticed it that I saw on Twitter.
So do you see that?
Because she's a Lego prick, right?
right here right like oh my god
yeah she's built like a one piece character and it clicked
it like I saw a twitter feed about it I was like oh my god
wait because you know they're legos what a patty yeah they
draw her waist on the brick and it never clicked in my head
that that she damn she's a baddie i get it now i get why
emma was like so in love with her you guys see it yeah just
literally feel like a one-piece kick dude like what the fuck
why what
okay anyway i was just thinking about that because i was
looking at cat woman because she has it too But it's not,
it's, okay, yes, Catwoman has it too, but it's like not as
bad as this.
Because like, you know, it's just a little bit of space
there, you know, a little bit of the hips.
But this one is like one piece.
Yeah, I thought she was just wearing a hoodie.
It looked like she was wearing a hoodie, but, I mean, she is
wearing a hoodie, but, but my God, she is wearing a child
size, I think.
yeah good thing i like a challenge i think it's like one
size two sizes too small
that wall looks like something i could really think my
clothes oh i can walk that didn't have the time to get your
nails done i'll stick with my back claw thanks yeah let me
pull that Yeah, better proportions than Catwoman.
Or it's just crazy to think about.
Because it's literally Catwoman.
Oh, you're right.
She was Batman's ex.
That's true.
It all makes sense now.
Batman knows what he's into.
I have an upgrade available.
Or is it this?
Why is there like it?
Oh, oh, I could literally change the colors.
I didn't even realize that.
Oh my god, I could be blue.
I would be blue, though.
I could be green.
I'm sorry, that green looks so ugly.
I'm sorry.
Can he change his colors?
Oh my god, I can.
I could be green, too!
I'm gonna be green.
Where are you, Batman?
Wait, why aren't you green?
There we- oh my god.
That looks so bad on him.
How did he see me?
Oh, the camera.
Don't worry.
There's no way he knows now.
What the fuck I couldn't count it at?
No that's green, it's just a light.
It's just a lighting.
How cliche, but if Penguin thinks he can keep Catwoman out
in the cold, he's dead wrong.
What's this?
Oh, Paul.
Well, well.
That could be just the boost I need.
Oh, that should have been something for Batman to do.
But also, but I don't want to break the stuff here.
It's like neon-esque green.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let me pull this for...
Alright, you climb.
You pull.
You climb.
Keep an eye on things while I prowl.
around okay i'm batman vigilance is my middle name all right
we go this way i'm prowling i'm prowling
all right yep never expected that did you there must be a
way to turn off this pesky ice machine I think I did it.
This should warm things up.
I don't want to be catwoman.
Meow.
Huh?
Me?
Use this.
Not Batman probably has some fancy gadget for this type of
thing.
It does?
Why am I scanning?
My thermal vision will lead me straight to the shutoff
valve.
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
it's right here how do i get into it it's really right
inside
oh i have to like fully scan it all right fire no fire
cobblepot's henchmen have this place locked down we'll need
to get that door open to move forward
i guess we go this way
oh goodbye no saxophone playing here Axophone.
That's where I said it.
Oh.
Maybe Catwoman will help me with the other person.
Oh, that's all right.
You go looking pretty over there.
It's all right.
Let's go and look beautiful.
That's your job.
Grab this.
That everything?
Oh, I knew there was something over here.
get there.
Oh, nice.
I guess it was just that easy.
Yeah, Wayne Tech.
Hello.
Not creepy at all.
Oops, I didn't see you there.
Yeah, I need a glad.
Very nice.
Timed it perfectly.
and then activate a
dead end a little mr.
penguin that penguin oh that's not creepy
we're just here to talk my name's not oswald it's penguin I
am not a human being I'm an animal I think he might need a
therapist.
He might be off his meds, guys.
Nobody knows.
Oh, shit.
Are they real penguins?
Are they robots?
What are they?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, they're not.
They're not real penguins.
I just hope they're not real penguins.
I...
It would be insane if those were real penguins.
Penguins!
Nice.
What?
Guys, I'm not a bad person.
They decided to explode.
They wanted to explode themselves.
Guys, guys, I'm pretty...
Maybe they're toys, guys.
Maybe they're toys.
Yeah, if you touch a penguin a little too much, it just
starts combusting.
Even think about it.
Kabbalah hates it when people touch his stuff.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, man.
I love the things in here, though.
No?
Gotta stay focused if I want that promotion.
No one's a match for my cat-like reflex.
We're making progress.
Nobody knows.
You think you'll play Arkham Knight or Origen someday?
So you probably answered a million times.
But I'm a casual boonier.
My being.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I try to finish a series as much as I can.
We have played Arkham City last time.
So which one's after Arkham City?
Oh.
Yay.
Oh, that doesn't...
Oh, yes!
Invulnerability Frames!
Oh, is it Arkham Night After?
Oh, you're very, very busy.
Let's use this vent.
Look at all this junk.
Ugh.
Penguin has way too much time on his greasy flippers.
You guys!
Ugh, Penguin's tacky umbrellas.
Hmm.
They might actually come in handy here.
But I swapped this.
Why are you eating?
I would assume it's that way.
You need to start building or something?
Ah, there you go.
Ah!
Fuck this guy, though.
Yay!
Oh, I got got Gothic modifier?
Oh.
Ninja, toxic waste.
What?
How is that?
That's that, that's purple.
It's just, it's just purple, right?
Got it.
That's just, that's just, that's just, that's past, yeah,
that's past, like, excuse me.
Oh, why is she purple?
That's the, I guess, I mean, sure?
I said no bad to that.
we should be able to cut through this glass with the right
set of claws there's something over here it says no bats
allowed you gotta tell me what to do another job for me well
you know what they say a thief's work is never done
looking for you i can't read
oh there it is i think a bug because apparently I'm supposed
to be Eevee.
Alright.
I get in here.
And grab another upgrade.
Yay!
A new toy, huh?
Sheesh.
Oh, another one!
Alright.
Athena, they give this to Breeze.
chat thank you thank you yeah i got another upgrade he knows
what he is what if he has to what if he has to pee well i
guess what does he do if he what if like during crimes like
you know saving the city during crime hours he needs to use
the bathroom is there a zipper
There's a zipper.
Do you have to hold it in until he gets home?
I'm not against a little DIY.
Alright, I'll build a new boat.
That's a better boat.
Perfect.
Now we'll be able to control the water level.
Oh, it's not even a boat.
It's just me.
Oh, it's just a...
It's just a giant plug.
Which means the catwalk is...
Oh.
That platform floats on the water.
Could be useful.
Okay, so one person.
I see.
That's why he made his suit yellow.
It all makes sense now.
Oh.
Alright, I'm supposed to be the one that does this and then
all right
god damn it oh and they say chivalry's dead
i'm just wondering what the green buttons are
all right here we go cats and water do not miss whoops whoa
whoa
oh no what would i do I'm so scared.
Ahem!
Oh shit!
Okay, I caught it.
Right away, my lady.
Not even close.
Clutch right there.
Let me go up here.
Alright, cat, just save those at least.
Ugh, how rude.
I bet the bat has something in that cowl of his that'll take
out these cameras.
Apparently that's a FNAF reference.
One of those...
Oh hey, little duck.
One of those said that they sneak that in as a Five Nights
at Freddy's reference.
Is that the bite of 69?
Okay, I assume...
Oh no, I got a drink!
I keep hitting things!
I can't help it!
I just see stuff and it makes me want to smash.
Hey, Batman.
I'm feeling a little lonely over here.
Alright, Batman.
Get over here.
Nice of you to join me.
Think you can do something about these cameras?
Alright, yeah.
I'm hacking.
I'm in?
There we go.
It's just that easy.
Press two buttons.
We need the Hannah.
Yeah, it's just that easy.
Yay!
Oh, we're so cute.
Look at us.
We're on our, it's like our first date or something.
You know, as friends, of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As friends.
You know, like a friend date.
Okay, clearly we have to do something.
over here.
Alright, we need a key, too.
Oh.
Up we go.
Now we're here.
Enough that.
Whee!
What the fuck do I do here?
Cat confused.
Whee!
Alright, clearly there's something here that I have to turn
off we'll leave him here whoops
oh I see it
alright alright cat go up now oh that's it oh cat picked
this up and 7 thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you there you go
alright Yay, more upgrades.
Okay.
Well, there's a button here.
That's the button.
Oh, shit!
It's alright.
There you go.
Just that easy.
Guys, just remember, these are...
Guys, those penguins.
Those penguins are toys.
They're not real penguins, guys.
Just remember.
No penguins were harmed.
They're just toys.
Okay.
All right, time to tag.
E for Batman.
Oh my god, even my foam is yellow.
I got another...
I like how they're all...
What the fuck?
It's the gate here.
What did you find?
It was just looking, Doki.
It was just hanging out.
Why?
Okay.
I mean, they're all using it on Batman, so like we should be
fine.
Okay, these guys are pretty inefficient, I will say.
Meredith is certified to operate that saw.
Let's shut it down.
Ciao.
Oh my god, they're real, they're not penguins!
Little bird should stay away from big bad kitty cats.
Nice.
all right that's convenient actually that's so convenient
all right where are you where's the bazooka man oh my god
bad man please that was my guy i called dibs
whoops sorry friendly fire
all right nice dodge them all I just punted him!
He's like, pp, pp, pp, pp, pp, pp, pp, pp, pp!
And I just literally just punted him away.
That's so dumb.
Alright.
Fatma, please!
Alright, nice.
Double kill.
Oh, that's Tom Kenny.
That's Tom Kenny.
I just realized.
I was like, that's the ice king.
He's literally using his ice king voice for penguins.
It has a nice ring to it.
Sounds like a nursery rhyme.
And those never end well.
I was like, wait a minute.
That's the ice king.
A moat.
Talk about old school.
It does look deep though.
I can't hear it now.
It's literally the ice king.
It's literally him.
I can't unhear it now.
Now that I realize it's Ice King.
It's the same person.
Oh.
Is it not Tom Kenny?
That literally is so similar.
I'd ask if you were joking.
It sounds so similar.
I can't believe it's not him.
He sounds...
That's literally a classic Tom Kenny voice.
Oh, that's good.
The shark spray.
That's looking great.
What's called the prep time?
I have prep time.
It's always like, who would win Batman and Superman?
But then you're like, yeah, but how much does Batman...
What's the prep time for Batman?
Batman.
Get in.
You might want to hold on to your cat ears.
That's right.
I have everything.
Oh shit, never mind.
Apparently the shark repell- Oh, there you go.
Shark begun!
Oh, he saw it.
What a rush.
Let's do that again.
I think the shark's still recovering.
The amphitheater.
That must be where Oswald is hiding.
Why wouldn't he have a shark repellent?
A shark can come from anywhere.
You'll never know.
You'll never know when there was some shark attack.
Yeah, never know when you might need it.
I ain't standing someone as cute as you out there.
monster
I don't know how much she's paying you but you made a big
mistake coming here Oswald we just have some questions Yeah,
we know how that goes.
You try and run me over with a batmobile Um, time to fly the
nest sorry No
Not the type of bath I enjoy You two just don't give up Get
him Oh my god He was replaceable How could he You chumps are
gonna regret messing with me What the fuck?
Oh my god oh my
That's awkward.
Wait.
Try to whip him!
What if I...
Wait, can I whip him into the ocean?
Oh, shit.
Wait, I have an idea.
Wait, this is what I wanted to do.
No!
Give me a sec.
Wait, can I do that to him?
No!
He won't let me.
He won't let me grab him.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Get whipped.
That's fucking right.
Get sunlocked.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
No!
Me too.
Before I die!
That's like you're right.
Get out of here.
Oh, I can't whip him anymore?
That's alright, I have a combo.
Color me unimpressed.
Yeah, this ain't over, you miserable stretcher.
Yeah, you better swim away Creep A list of bribes for his
mayoral campaign So his business dealings are fishy Tell the
surprise So how did Harley got elected as mayor I knew he
was behind those moronic minds
He's back phase two
Oh my god he brought it duck with him duck tank oh shit can
I whip that guys I don't think I can whip the duck tank I
don't think I can whip it
what I'm gonna swap and gear please how do I maybe I whip
the back one takes all I need to lift that rocket back in
Yeah, it's good.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Let's keep whipping.
There you go.
There it is.
We just keep...
Just beat him up.
Alright, I get it.
You can whip him.
Watch this.
It's just that easy.
Alright, nice.
Nice, there you go.
Alright, R1.
That's fucking right.
Wait, can I R1?
No!
Oh, it doesn't overlap.
Okay.
It's alright.
Catwoman would be fine.
Alright, just keep punching.
There we go.
Sorry, Batman.
You can take it, Batman, I believe!
There we go.
Oh, I couldn't catch me.
Oh, who is it?
Who is the real player?
Ah, shit.
So I started blasting.
That's like my strat.
Whoa.
Why dodge?
Whoa, shit.
swap character what the fuck what the fuck okay where did he
come from do you guys see that oh shit oh wait hey I'm back
never punished let's go all right Look at that.
Never punished.
Yay!
Now you'll pay for what you never did.
I didn't die.
Didn't die.
I didn't die, guys.
You're talking about, you filthy fleabag.
I didn't die.
I was so alive.
Eliminating past less than savory associates.
world's greatest detective everybody I am way off the mark I
found that right after my iceberg lounge got hit then they
came after me at City Hall whatever they are they knew all
about our stashes how much was in them and all our other
dirty secrets ain't that right whiskers whatever I'm out of
here, then.
Look, wait.
Ah, well, lesson learned.
But in the end, all the cows...
I'll never die.
Toots dead.
Who's holding the umbrella?
That's just a regular...
Yep.
Ha ha, that's not the gun umbrella.
He needs to label those.
Bleed on the mines.
But there's enough in here to put Oswald away for the next
few elections.
weeks see i told you guys they're not real i told you guys
no penguins were harmed no penguins were harmed in this
level oh thank god thank god
Yay!
I got skill break and I have Batman.
Oh my god.
Pre-cat woman?
Yeah, I don't think I'm ever getting any of those trophies.
I have yellow.
I have piss bat ninja.
I wonder what villain would be leaving the Joker cards.
Slowing me down.
Who does he think he is anyway?
Sneaking a beast.
out in the darkness.
He's like, I am the knight.
I am the knight.
Nobody will see me.
But it better be good.
This isn't over.
How so?
Bat hun.
They'll never see me.
Penguin's card.
It's printed over another image.
Why so it is?
A pair of jokers.
Winner takes all.
Well, whoever planted these has still got your money.
Ugh, don't remind me.
Where are they from?
They did the Lion King thing.
The Simbanala shit.
Before they...
End.
And so have I.
There must be more cards.
Can you see?
the love tonight.
When Nala gave Simba the bedroom eyes, they said, you know
what to do.
You know what I'm talking about, guys.
She gave him the eye signal.
She gave him the side.
We always go to the nicest places.
Can you feel the love tonight oh my god nice i also give oh
that i don't like that i don't why are my particles yellow
let me see of course alfred we'll keep an eye out tonight
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Banana, I think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
This reminds me of the time Batman and Robin spray-painted
themselves yellow in the yellow room, proceeded to beat up
Greenland in half its death since they're weak to the color
yellow.
That can't be.
That has to be in the comics, right?
That can't be real.
That seems like a thing that I see in the comics.
You know what?
guys I think you fly across the ocean look around one of the
zoo animals should be here well it should me oh where's the
wait a mirror cat it's too late where's the mirror cat is it
back there ah fuck it who cares it that seems like something
that you they would put in the comics
and anything can happen in the comics wait why did i stop
what why did i stop gliding
okay i can't always be there to save everybody i can't use
this
what's this why is it making me pull it
i'm gonna go grab the upgrade so wait what Oh Oh
Oh This is a job for someone else who?
Okay, apparently neither of us.
I don't think any of it.
I guess I need to unlock another character Is this a robin
thing?
Incoming crime alert look to be taking place and try porn Is
this another?
Yeah.
This has to be another... Yeah, come back later type thing.
Probably a Robin thing.
Probably needs this fucking stick or some shit.
Who's this guy?
Not really.
I can just leave.
I'm just gonna leave.
Give in.
Guys, don't give him what he wants.
See, he wants me to do his stupid riddles.
But if I don't do his stupid riddles, then he's nothing.
Then he has...
That's all he has.
And I don't give him...
And I don't give it to him.
Then he has nothing.
I fucked up.
No good.
Let me blow this up.
Nice.
That's right.
Alright, come over here guys.
No!
No, fuck it.
We'll just use...
I'll just have them kill his own teammates.
Wait, where is he?
Alright, just kill all his teammates.
Alright, get over here.
Damn, he's gonna jump on him.
Hello.
Ow.
That's not cool.
That's right.
This is...
We were right.
The Mimes beat us here.
Which means they must have left a Joker card.
Where could they have leave a Joker card?
The plot thickens.
Is the modern day really just like an ascended level of
Indra troll who is commuting everyone?
He interacts really?
Riddle me this.
He's just a guy.
He's just a captcha.
We should take a look at that van.
Oh, there's the van.
This van?
Oh, that van!
Oh, the one that says mind your own business.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Did I open it?
What did I open this car?
Excuse me?
Oh, there it is.
My residue?
What the fuck is he leaving?
Oh my god, they have to start it all the way.
I just wanted to get there faster.
Oh my god, they have to follow it all the way.
Are you- I can't take shortcuts?
Okay, I'm not allowed to take shortcuts.
Why?
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'll follow it exactly.
I'm actually not...
I have to follow the path exactly as it's written.
I can't even take a shortcut.
No cheating allowed.
That woman knows saves better than anyone, including me.
I
was like, slowly, I'm going to slowly drop it.
And I was like, slow.
There we go.
Yay!
Meow!
You're welcome.
Alright, there's another Joker card.
If we're going to identify the hidden image on these cards,
we need to find one more.
Oh, fine.
Where to next?
City Hall.
Alright.
So why City Hall?
You gotta file your taxes.
Batman doesn't pay taxes.
It's safe to assume they left a card at the scene.
As I said before, I'm the world's greatest.
Ooh.
Alright, there you go.
That's right.
Billionaires don't need to pay taxes.
How else do we stay billionaires?
Okay, I wasn't supposed to go that way.
I thought it would lead there, but I guess not.
Can I make that?
I don't think so.
I think I'm going to have to do these.
I have to use the bridge like a commoner.
I got some in my car.
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
I wish I could get my hands a new tool.
Oh, there it is.
Sorry garbage truck
Hello emergency Don't worry don't worry citizens.
I got them Batman is here to protect and serve
Leaving the vehicle would be a bad idea What's going on I
hope you're here to help, because I've got my hands full
with these mines.
Just like every other cop in Gotham.
Once I get them to the station, I can...
Hey, what?
Oh, shit!
Well, here they go.
Oh, my God, they just broke up.
Broke in like that.
I feel like being a goon must definitely pay more.
How's there less cops than goons?
Who gave these mines a riot shield?
That's it.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
These mines are stronger than they look.
Get tied!
Nice.
I performed 100 successful counters.
Wait, actually, I wonder.
I wonder.
Wait, I was able to grab her before.
Let me grab you.
Oh.
Wait, I think I can make it work.
I think I can...
Let me grab you.
There we go.
I told you.
I told you!
It does work!
True love.
It really is.
Get out of here.
Yeah, she has nine lives.
It's okay, exactly.
Wish you'd left a couple for me.
Anyway, can I help you with something?
Have you seen a Joker card around here?
Instead of going to jail, we sent them to the hospital.
yay that's a negative batman there was a giant jack in the
box but it was taken to the station as evidence oh no he's
gonna come out of the jack in the box let's head to the gcpd
i doubt they've unloaded the evidence yet the address is
sorry boys have had it to
protect them sir don't worry the streets are safe when i'm
here I would have driven them back here
The streets are so safe When I'm here Alright, we're here
now
Hello That's not standard issue GCP to uniform Let's go Is
he okay?
Or talk to me
Alright Alright What am I supposed to do with that?
Like...
Uh...
Is there a hose anywhere?
Oh.
Or I'll help you.
That was just...
See, I helped.
Yay!
What do I help you?
Oh, I have an idea.
Oh, that's really far.
That seems like a good idea.
Oh, why to build something?
Alright, what am I building?
I'm building a car wash.
A brick wash.
Alright, start whipping.
Oh.
All right, start whipping.
Don't worry, I cleaned you.
You're clean now.
A cop wash.
Condiments.
So many condiments.
I don't know who he was.
He just yelled that he'd be taking my squad car.
And then the world was all tomato paste.
Oh no!
My car had all the evidence from City Hall.
inside too maybe i'm the one who truly dropped the mustard
not the mustard warehouse on the west side got it all right
let me spot in my car Free stock on coffee.
Batman.
I feel like people don't drive a sidewalks more.
There's so much grass here.
Especially when nobody is using it.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, we grabbed.
Yep, we're here.
The smell of a base.
side baseball field on open there's more ketchup exactly
more condiments we must be in the right place what the cat
woman can get up there can i turn him i'm weak oh the power
is off good thing i sharpen my claws no climb this easily no
no no no done perfectly Hey!
What time is it?
Oh, okay.
Now he can eat.
All right.
Give me a sec.
I can give him his full food now.
Got him his food.
Okay.
All right.
All right, now turn it.
What?
Huh?
You not turn it fully?
Batman, come on!
Oh, okay, I did not turn it fully.
You're on your guard.
Batman's here!
Oh, I need this condiment king!
It's him!
Oh my god.
That fucking condiment king.
It's coming with us.
I mean, I see kite man, though.
I can't believe he's real.
I'll smell like a hot dog stand after this.
You think I'm okay?
Where's the rest of this stuff?
Kite man's arch enemy.
It's alright, I'm here.
That's fucking right.
He's pure evil!
Look at all the condiments he wasted!
Looks like our ketchup enthusiast drops something.
Maybe we could use it.
This box is broken.
Let's see if we can find something to repair it.
Let's try it.
What is this?
Oh, it's over here.
We can use that handle to get into the box.
Yay!
This is the last one we need.
Time to put them all together.
Alright.
What does this say?
I recognize this painting.
Paper ham linking?
It's on display in the flugelheim.
God, Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's go to the flugelheim.
We can leave this condiment lover here.
What is this crime anyway?
Like didn't he has didn't he buy the condiments fair and
square though?
What could his crime be?
If loving condiments is a crime Then arrest me officer
Vandalism I think
we should use the front door.
It looks like it's locked anyway.
All right, we'll go up here Looks like we'll need to use an
unconventional entrance all right cut glass the vehicle
would be a bad idea think i best leave this to catwoman
don't worry i've done this before i'm sure you have
but stop thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
dad starts barking when you clap you should slap me in the
mix so he thinks you're clapping we both win let's broaden
our mind There he is!
Joker!
Jokler!
Bum-bum.
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
He's so silly.
Look at him.
Not even doing anything wrong.
Oh my god, there's no screen.
It's just art.
He's just trying to cheer up the city.
Try and make the city happier.
Make it laugh.
Just trying to party.
What's going on here?
This place seems nice.
I should come back for another visit.
I assume you mean during opening hours.
I see, yeah, I knew it.
I knew it was the boom box.
All right, we're going to call it here because we have a lot
of very long streams this week.
And I do want to play more, but I have to be more mindful of
my vocal cords this week because I just remembered I have to
talk.
I might have to talk a lot next week.
So I hate it because I do want to play long.
But then I do have a James Bond stream tomorrow, which I'm
also super looking forward to because the reviews have been
really, really good.
And also more armored court, too.
And then there's the Matara collab.
And then also, two Apex collab.
And I'm, oh my god, I might have fucked up a little bit
because I was like, it's all right.
I'll be gone next week.
I won't be streaming much next week.
But I forgot, wait, you won't be streaming much next week.
But you're still going to have to do a lot of talking next
week.
And I'm like, fuck.
All right.
So I got to be more mindful.
You can't stream too long, which sucks because I really
wanted to.
Hey, guys.
That's fun.
It's been fun so far.
I love all the little references, the callbacks and
everything.
And it's been fun for my very first Lego game.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
19%.
okay all right anyway guys um guys as always everyone say hi
to the posh check get them around get that blood flow stuff
from me at the bed because you deserve it the ending screen
is the ending there's new updates to the ending screen guys
so save to the end and you want to see all the new dokees
added bye bye everybody bye you